Ja, herzlich willkommen zur Alternativlos die Folge Nr. 19. Und wenig überraschend wird es heute um den Staatstrojaner gehen. Und bei uns zu Gast ist heute mal wieder Constanze Kurz.
Na.
Und.
Herzlich willkommen.
Und Fefe. Na. Ist auch da.
Wir sagen mal der Sicherheit halber an, dass wir hier nicht in offizieller position sind.
Wir sind hier vollkommen privat.
Wir sind ganz privat hier. Wir haben nur zufällig zwei, drei Einblicke, die wir mit euch teilen werden.
Wir werden hier auch irgendwie keine TTC-Meinung droppen, sondern wir reden hier einfach mal frei raus.
Etwaige Überschneidungen sind rein zufällig.
Und nicht beabsichtigt. Und während der Erstellung dieser Sendung wurden keine Ratten getötet.
Ja, ist wichtig.
Naja, das können wir so sicher noch nicht ansagen.
Na gut, wir geben uns zumindest Mühe.
Wenn ihr zwischendurch einer quiktet, dann bin das sicherlich ich.
Ja, also zum Hintergrund, wir sitzen gerade im Chaos Computer Club Berlin und wir züchten hier Dinge. Gibt es hier Gerüchte über?
Na gut, das sind nur Gerüchte, aber sie haben genug, dass Frank immer auf dem Boden guckt.
Florian Fauner, die hier.
Können wir mal zum Thema kommen?
Gut, ja, der Bundestrojaner.
Ist doch das Thema ungebetene Gäste.
Er hat schon wieder Bundestrojaner gesagt.
Ich habe nicht Bundestrojaner, ich habe Staatstrojaner gesagt.
Behördentrojaner.
Ich sage Bundeswanze.
Ich finde ja Bundestrojaner immer noch gut, weil wir das so schön eingeführt haben.
Ich finde ja Staatsstrojaner am besten. Also wir sehen alles Vor-
und Nachteile.
Wir haben eine kleine Sprachverwirrung, deswegen sollten wir vielleicht einfach mit ein wenig Geschichte anfangen. Wie kam es denn eigentlich zu dieser ganzen bundestrojaner-staatstrojaner-diskussion? Also wo kam denn der ganze Threat her?
Die Idee war eigentlich deshalb entstanden, weil es einen Streit gab um eine sogenannte Online-Suchung und ob es dafür schon eine Rechtsgrundlage gab. Und der ursprüngliche Beginn war mal eine Online-Suchung, die sie durchführen wollten und wo es zum Streit kam. Und der BGH darüber befinden sollte, ob es eigentlich eine Rechtsgrundlage dafür gibt. Und damals hat der BGH gesagt, nein, dafür gibt es keine Rechtsgrundlage. Denn man könne auch nicht zu sagen, sich das irgendwie zu zusammenziehen aus der Strafprozessordnung. Und dann müsse man eine eigene Rechtsgrundlage schaffen. Das war so ein bisschen der Anfang. Und das war, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, Anfang 2007?
Eigentlich war weniger explorativ, als du das jetzt darstellst, oder? Eigentlich haben wir doch nicht rausfinden wollen, ob es legal ist, sondern wir wollten gern festgestellt sein, dass es nicht legal ist.
Du, das mag sein. Naja, nee, also ich glaube, es war einfach die Zeit, wo es losging, wo sie bemerkt haben, dass es überhaupt technisch geht. Dass es eine Möglichkeit wäre, als Ermittlungswerkzeug. Ich glaube, das war eigentlich der Beginn. Und danach, ganz kurz danach, wurde klar, dass damals, das war noch der Dewell, der Staatssekretär, da so einen Erlass rausgelassen hatte, um also quasi eine Unabhängigung zu erlauben, aber ohne eine richtige gesetzliche Grundlage. Das war so ein bisschen der Beginn der Debatte.
Vielleicht sollten wir nochmal kurz erwähnen, wozu wollen die dann eigentlich immer so eine Unabhängigung haben? Also was dann eigentlich der argumentation der Strafverfolgungsbehörden und...
Ja klar, das war am Anfang ja noch so ein bisschen wischiwaschi, aber ging ziemlich schnell um Internet-Telefonie, das war auch immer klar, ging um Passwörter und danach kam erst mal in der ganzen Weile nichts in den ersten argumentationen.
Also um nochmal den Kontext ein bisschen weiter aufzuziehen, der eigentliche Hintergrund dieser Geschichte mit dem Staatstrojaner-Online-Durchsuchung ist ja, dass wir die Crypto Wars gewonnen haben.
Was schon ein bisschen zurücklegt.
Was schon ein bisschen zurücklegt, also was das heißt, ist man darf verschlüsseln und es kann einem dabei niemand reinreden, wie man verschlüsselt und man kann auch mittlerweile bestätigt vom Verfassungsgericht dieses digitale Selbstverteidigungsrecht einfach wahrnehmen und verschlüsseln, was das Zeug hält.
Das heißt natürlich, dass einem nicht Nachteile eventuell dadurch reichen.
Moment, aber du musst auch den Schlüsseln irgendwo hinterlegen, das war ja auch so ein Versuch zwischendurch.
Also es gibt halt keine Möglichkeit für die Ermittlungsbehörden, außer sie brechen eure Passphrase oder ihr benutzt schwache Krypto, an die Inhalte von verschlüsselten Sachen zu kommen, es sei denn, sie infiltrieren den Computer. Das war sozusagen der, so mehr oder minder der unausgesprochene Deal. Okay, ihr habt die Kryptowars gewonnen, dafür wollen wir in der Lage sein, eure Computer zu infiltrieren. Und diese argumentation zieht sich ja durch alle Sachen durch, angefangen von Festplattenverschlüsselung über verschlüsselte E-Mail.
Das war einfach dann irgendwie ein Massencharakter angenommen. Ich glaube, es fing damit an, dass der Bitlocker in Windows einfach, ich glaube, in der professional version damals einfach drin war, der erste Mal.
Naja, das liegt auch schon ein paar Jahre zurück, das klang irgendwie 2008 oder so, bei Vista war das, glaube ich.
Na schon, aber also, das ist jetzt die Zeit.
Wie ist denn das zeitlich mit dem Hacker-Tool-Verbot? Das war noch auch so.
Das war schon noch ein bisschen später, eineinhalb Jahre später. Aber die Cybercrime convention war da schon, also war ja da schon aktuell.
Gut, aber jedenfalls, um sozusagen zu diesem großen Kontext zurückzukommen, worum es ja geht, ist die diskussion, was dürfen Ermittlungsbehörden, unter welchen Umständen dürfen sie auf unsere Daten, unsere kommunikation zugreifen? Und daraus resultierte ja dann eben diese, mehr oder minder weitreichende Ermächtigung in dem, ich glaube, nordrhein-westfälischen Verfassungsschutzgesetz, was...
Ja, aber das war ja sozusagen noch der letzte Schritt.
Das war ja sozusagen der Testcase, der vom Verfassungsgericht gelangert ist.
Und es war auch noch ein grottendummer Testcase, weil dieses Gesetz so schlecht formuliert war, dass eigentlich alle wussten, das kann man nur verlieren. Und dann hatten sie ja dann auch noch einen Anwalt, der sozusagen die nordrhein-westfälische Regierung verteidigen sollte. Der hat natürlich den Beschwerdeführer in die Hände gespielt.
Das war nicht so direkt die Leuchte seiner Zunft.
Er hatte aber auch wenig in der Hand, weil das Gesetz war schlecht.
Ist das nicht eigentlich bei den meisten Gesetzen so? Das fällt noch nicht so auf, weil keiner klagt.
Ja, es ist also schon so, dass die handwerkliche Qualität von Gesetzen durchaus eine Rolle spielt bei solchen Sachen. Aber in diesem Fall war es halt eben so, dass es um sehr viele grundsätzliche Sachen ging. Denfalls spüren wir mal ein bisschen vor zu diesem Prozess vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, wo ja eigentlich alle Argumente dazu relativ klar benannt wurden. Oder hast du noch einen Punkt, den du noch durchbauen wolltest?
Ja, ich finde die Vorgeschichte so gänzlich. Aber na gut, wir spüren sie vor. Also ich fand schon interessant, was es da von Hicka gab, wenn ihr euch erinnert, an den Staatssekretär Diewell. Und die Frage wäre diesen Erlass, der trotzdem, wie ist die Online-Untersuchung da? Am Anfang haben sie übrigens auch noch Online-Untersuchung gesagt. Fällt mir ein. Später wurde das Online-Durchsuchung. Und dann gab es noch Anhörungen im Bundestag zu der Zeit. Also es war noch richtig hickack, bevor es dann an die Beschwerdeverfahren gab. Aber das scheint euch ja gut zu erinnern. Die Frühgeschichte der Bundeswand scheint hier nicht so zu interessieren. Nein, wir reden über den NRW-Gesetz. Das war ja nicht der entscheidende Punkt.
Also der interessante Punkt daran war, dass neben der Vorratsansprechung bei der diskussion unter dem Bundestrojaner damals sicherlich einer der Punkte, der richtig viele Leute mobilisiert hat. Also wo halt viele Leute sich betroffen fühlten, sich ja persönlich angegriffen fühlten und halt einfach auch fürchteten, dass irgendwie ihr Computer infiltriert wird und ihre Daten dabei verloren gehen.
Genau und das kam auch noch gleichzeitig wieder in die Zeit, wo plötzlich irgendwann war eine Mehrheit da von Menschen, die Rechner benutzen. Und die Smartphones waren seit ein paar Jahren immer häufiger. Also, ich glaube, das spielt immer noch eine Rolle, dass plötzlich viele Leute nachvollziehen konnten, das ist hier mein ausgelagertes Gehirn. Das war einfach die richtige Zeit, um sich mal ordentlich darüber zu streiten, auch über die Presse.
Und es gab einfach auch eine Sache, die man angreifen konnte. So ein Erlass kann man eigentlich nur angreifen, wenn man selbst betroffen ist. Und der Nachweis ist ja nicht wirklich zu erbringen.
Oh ja, dann auch nicht mehr nötig.
Ja, aber ich meine, ich würde sagen, das Erste, was man richtig schön angreifen kann, und wo wir es natürlich auch gemacht haben, ist eben, als dann der Gesetzentwurf kam. Insofern ist das nicht nur, dass die Zeit reif war, sondern es war auch das erste richtig schöne Ziel, was wir angreifen konnten.
Ja, und das war tatsächlich dann auch an der Zeit, weil die Behörden angefangen haben, es halt einfach zu setzen. Also die haben es ja einfach da angefangen zu verwenden.
Na, und dann finde ich, am Anfang war es ja auch noch so, dass mussten ganz viele von den technischen Details erstmal geklärt werden. Im politischen Raum gab es überhaupt keine Vorstellung davon, was eine Online-Durchsuchung überhaupt sein soll. Und wie ein Trojaner geht und so, da war gar nichts, das musste man erstmal erklären.
Ist ja eigentlich immer noch, oder? Also mein Eindruck war immer, dass es so ein bisschen diese Bergsteiger-Erklärung ist. Wir steigen auf den Berg, weil er da ist, weil wir können.
Because we can.
Ja, also ich glaube nicht, dass irgendein Politiker wirklich wissen wollte, was man jetzt damit erreichen kann, sondern die Polizei hat sich halt hingestellt, hat gesagt, ja ja, die Terroristen kommen. Und alles, was wir tun können gegen Al-Qaeda, das war ja nun auch.
Stimmt, die Terrorismus-Koile haben sie immer gebracht.
Die Terrorismus-Koile war von Anfang an. Nee, nicht nur die Datenbank auch so Sachen wie die.
Also Al-Qaeda die Datenbank.
Nein, dass die Leute sich in irgendwelchen Webforen radikalisieren und es kamen dann noch diese, die, die, also eine der, weil man weiß ja immer nicht, wie viel davon Schutzbehauptung ist, aber es kam dann diese Geschichte durch die Presse, dass die Leute eben keine Mails verschicken, die man ja abhören konnte legal, sondern dass die irgendein Web-Mail-System benutzen und das dann immer abspeichern unter Drafts oder so was. Und deswegen brauchen wir die online-distruktion. Das war so eine der wenigen, ich will jetzt nicht sagen stichhaltigen, aber der Argumente, die so nicht völlig offensichtlich schwach waren.
Die haben so ein Wohnpostfach bei Yahoo oder so.
Genau. Und das war so eines der argumentationen, warum wir einen Trojaner brauchen, damit wir diese Drafts lesen können. Ein witziger Nebeneffekt von diesen Argumenten war auch immer, dass die Betreiber von solchen Systemen wie Skype oder Web-Mail-Systemen, dass die natürlich auch Firmen sind, die irgendwo einen Sitz haben und Gesetzen unterliegen. Und dass die auch ein Interesse daran haben, natürlich als nicht die Firma dazustehen, die Al-Qaeda beherbergt. Deswegen kam eigentlich jedes Mal, wenn die mit einem von diesen Dingern kamen, dann die entsprechende Firma aus dem Unterholz und meinte, naja, na klar, kann man das hier abhören, wir müssen einfach mit uns reden. Besonders peinlich war das bei Skype, fand ich. Ja, ja, hat das glaube ich auch gesagt, aber Skype meinte halt ziemlich sofort, als damals diese Sache...
Auf der Webseite stand das sogar.
Ja, aber wir sind doch hier in Luxemburg und da müssen sie doch noch mal fragen, war die Ansage von Skype, na klar, können wir abhören?
Das wollte ich ja nicht anders, da müssen wir vielleicht mal generell sagen, dass alle kommunikationsfähige gesetzliche Abhörschnittstellen haben. Wahrscheinlich aber die Hörer dieses exklusiven Podcasts wahrscheinlich schon wissen.
Natürlich. Diese Geschichte mit Skype ist halt insofern auch interessant, als dass Deutschland offensichtlich zumindest das einzige Land auf dem Globus zu sein scheint, wo irgendwie die Ermittlungsbehörden es nicht hinbekommen, mal die richtigen Formulare dahin zu schicken. Also wir wissen aus der Zeit…
Na ja, Moment. Skype hat ja gesagt, du musst einen richterlichen Beschluss…
Ja, musste auch so für…
Und?
Das ist ja der Punkt eigentlich, dass eigentlich unser Verdacht schon ziemlich früh ist, dass wenn du den Leuten Trojanen gibst, dass sie denen dann eben auch so Gefahr im Verzug mäßig einsetzen, ohne wirklich autorisiert zu sein. Und das geht natürlich nicht, wenn jemand wie Skype penetrant auf richterlichen Beschlüssen beruht. Also das ist so meine persönliche Theorie, warum wir immer noch Trojaner brauchen.
Also wir wissen ja, dass im nicht europäischen Ausland zum Beispiel Skype auch größere interception-center betreibt. Also teilweise auch in den Ländern. Das heißt also diese Ansage, Skype ist nicht in der Lage abzuhören, ist zumindest evident falsch. Und die Frage, warum, die Frage ist halt, warum die deutschen Behörden da immer noch drauf stehen, dass es also um Skype geht. Und wir haben ja schon sehr lange die Vermutung, dass es eigentlich nur darum ging, dass sie ein weitergehendes Vermittlungswerkzeug haben wollten. Also nämlich als Santroyaner und Skype halt eben nur als Ausrede oder Vehikel benutzt haben, um da hinzukommen, also um dieses Ziel zu erreichen. Weil wir können Skype nicht abhören, kann man so ein Politiker halt schon mal irgendwie vermitteln so als großes Problem.
Das war immer diese typische Phrase von wir sind auf diesem Kanal blind und taub.
Genau, das war so der Klassiker. Und der rechtsfreie Raum. Naja, ja, dann haben wir schon einen Teil der Argumente, die während der Anhörung beim Bundesverfassungsgericht kamen.
Festplattenverschüßung noch, da ist natürlich, da kann man natürlich schlecht gegenargumentieren. Also im Sinne von einem technischen Argument argumentieren.
Da muss man ja auch nicht. Ich sag's nur, ja. Also an sich ist es ja genau vom Verfassungsgericht gesagt, nicht nur bei Online-Sachen, sondern auch ansonsten gibt es einen Kernbereich und der ist absolut unantastbar.
Der besteht nicht aus einer Festplatte der Kernberichte.
Nein, aber...
Bei dir vielleicht schon.
Na ja, natürlich, bei dir auch. Also wenn du dann den Flash in deinen mobilen Geräten dazurechnest...
Ich hab keinen Flash. Also ich habe keinen Flash und du wirst dir keinen Flash-Runt abziehen.
Und meine Flash im Sinne von Speicher jetzt.
Bei mir drehen die Festplatten noch. In deinem Mobiltelefon? Nicht so.
Also ich denke mal, wenn man das dazu zählt, dann würde ich das durchaus bejahen wollen, dass das zum Kernbereich gehört. Also grundsätzlich...
Der Kernbereich ist schon definiert. Der Kernbereich meint wirklich, also damit meint die...
Nein, aber ist klar, aber das ist ja im Grunde was wir sagen wollen, dass du beim modernen Menschen das nicht mehr so trennen kannst. Auf meinem Laptop sind genug private Sachen, dass man nicht einfach sagen kann, wir tun da jetzt eine Wanze drauf.
Genau. Das ist die argumentation. Nicht etwa, dass der Gesamte in deiner Festplatte zu deinem Kernbereich der privaten Lebensbestellung gehören würde, sondern, dass du im Prinzip nicht unterscheiden kannst und quasi zwangsläufig damit auch sehr private Daten erlangen könntest.
Wie haben die denn reagiert, als wir das gesagt haben? Das war ja auch ganz spannend.
Das Verfassungsgericht arbeitet ja immer so, dass sie bei solchen Anhörungen vorher alle möglichen Leute um Stellungnahme bitten. Meistens mit einem sehr detaillierten Fragenkatalog. Also zu den Problemen, die sie halt schon vorher bei der Durchsicht des Problems und der anliegenden Klagen zusammengestellt haben.
Vor allen Dingen aus den Beschwerdeschriftsetzen. Die haben ja schon immer die Probleme.
Das sind halt im Wesentlichen schon sehr detaillierte Fragen.
Es waren nicht so sehr viele bei der anderen Durchsuchung.
Nee, es waren zwölf oder dreizehn oder sowas. Es waren eher so nicht so viele. Und die waren aber doch schon sehr knackig und detailliert. Also da ging es halt schon noch deutlich zur Sache.
Sie wollten das vor allen Dingen technisch erklärt haben, weil das war das allererste Mal, dass das Gericht gleich fünf technische Sachverständige hatte, die sich, glaube ich, auch interessant das eigentlich fast überhaupt nicht abgesprochen haben. Das weiß ich gar nicht, ob das heute noch so passieren würde. Also die Gutachten wurden eigentlich alle unabhängig verfasst. Das würde man heute vielleicht gar nicht mehr haben.
Ja, aber so soll es ja eigentlich auch sein, ne?
Ja, durchaus. Also das war, glaube ich, ein Novum, dass das Gericht fünf, also weil üblicherweise natürlich die Sachverständigen bei diesen Anhörungen dann meistens die Osten sind, dann sind ja auch oft die ostische Probleme. Aber hier hatten sie halt, ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir die fünf noch zusammenkriegen.
Fitzmann war dabei, ne?
Natürlich, der verstorbene Fitzmann, der hatte das Haus gerockt. Für den CCC war es Andreas Buruk, der auch vorgetragen hat in einem supergeilen Konfirmantenanzug.
Ach Mensch, du sei doch witzig.
Nein, er war mit Abstand der kurze Hacker davon allen. Dann war da noch Professor Freilink, ich glaube aus Mannheim. Das war ein sehr technisches Papier.
Gut, die anderen muss man jetzt noch zusammen.
Na doch Siebert noch, ne? Vier, aber vier oder fünf? Oder hab ich jetzt schon fünf.
Die Anhörung selber war durchaus echt sehenswert, muss man sagen. Also sowohl was irgendwie die Art und Weise, wie sich da der Anwalt der Regierung blamiert hat. Das hat einen harzhaften Popcorn- Unterhaltungsfaktor, muss man sagen.
Naja, wir waren da auch das erste Mal da. Wir hatten das ja vorher noch nie gesehen.
Das ist richtig, aber trotzdem war es schon so, dass es also eine sehenswerte...
Absolut. Ich hatte keine Ahnung, wie hochwertig diese Debatten sein würden. Ich fand das erst einmal total faszinierend, denn wir hatten, ich glaube, in der CCC-Pressearbeit und so bestimmt ein Jahr lang intensiv immer wieder über ID-technische Details geredet. Und die haben das auf so einem coolen, hohen Niveau gemacht, dass es einfach total angenehm war, die fünf Stunden oder sechs so zu hören. Das war richtig toll.
Also ich will nicht sagen, wir waren nicht überrascht. Wir waren erfreut über das Niveau.
Sehr erfreut, kann man so sagen.
Und überrascht waren wir eigentlich, dass wir nicht auf die Schnauze gekriegt haben von den Gegenüber, die das seit 50 Jahren machen, oder?
Ich weiß gar nicht, was mich am meisten überrascht hat. Mir hat Lobek am meisten überrascht, dass sich die technischen Sachverständigen so weitgehend einig waren. Und wie sehr Fitzmann, äh, Fitzmann hat einfach, ich sehe ihn auf das Gesicht. Fitzmann hat den Richtern erklärt, dass die Computer in die Körper wachsen werden. Und was wir jetzt vielleicht jetzt irgendwie nicht so ungewöhnlich finden, weil wir sofort eine Vorstellung irgendwie von Nanotechnologie haben und so weiter. Aber bei den Richtern hat man halt so gesehen, wie da so erstmal die Fragen waren in den Gesichtern. Und dann irgendwann so dieser Groschenfiel, bis die Mitte kriegt, was er meint. Und er war sehr kurz in den Gutachten. Und was er gesagt hat auch. Aber das hat total beeindruckt. Also er hat da schon echt einen Punkt gemacht. Und ja, viel war dann, also man muss sagen, die Befragung der offiziellen Stellen. Also Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz, BKA. War noch der Schar da. Und natürlich der Schar hat auch gesagt.
BSI war auch da, ne?
Ja, der BSI war da, aber nicht mit dem Chef. Der damals war noch der Helmbrecht. Der war das nicht. Der war noch jemand anders. Das stimmt. Das war auch. Und das Interessant war, dass es wurde so eine Art inquisition. Das artete so aus. Und am meisten blamiert hat sich da aus meiner Sicht auch noch der Bundes-, der Präsident des Bundesamts für Verfassungsschutz mit seinem Problem mit der Aussageberechtigung.
Uriah, jetzt erinnere ich mich da gerade wieder.
Also sowas hatte ich noch nie erlebt. Also A, wusste ich nicht, dass auch ein Verfassungsschutzpräsident eine Aussagegenehmigung braucht, um vom Gericht was zu sagen. Und er wurde da also befragt und er hat da auch ein bisschen rumgeeiert, aber er hat auch etwas Interessantes gesagt. Zum Beispiel, das wichtige Bitt hat für uns interessant, war, dass alles, was das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz da so macht, wegen der Amtshilfe käme. Alle haben sofort gewusst, hier ist der BND gemeint. Und während der also sprach, sprang irgendwann so ein kleines Männchen aus Reihe 4 hoch, rannte nach vorne ans Mikro und drängete sich davor und sagte, hier hat der Präsident keine Aussagegenehmigung mehr. Und dann war die Befragung zu Ende. So was bizarrert hatte ich noch nie gesehen.
Die Richter Popcorn rausgeholt oder was?
Da war ja noch der Papier und der hatte nur so seine Augenbrauen bis oben zum Haareinsatz. Ich wusste auch nicht, dass das passieren kann.
Das ist echt reales Tier.
Das war wirklich so was, das hab ich nicht erwartet.
Nee, das wäre zu peinlich, wenn wir jetzt weiter reden. Deswegen ziehen wir jetzt den Präsidenten ab.
Vor allen Dingen, es ist ja der Chef dieser Behörde. Welche Totsäme haben da von hinten? Wer hat eigentlich dann sozusagen die Macht, da vorzuspringen und zu sagen...
Kann eigentlich nur das Bundeskanzleramt sein. Die Aussagegenehmigung ist tatsächlich sein direkter Vorgesetzter, ist ja das Bundeskanzleramt.
Ja, gut, das stimmt. Jetzt gehst du wieder da so rational ran, na gut.
Naja, muss man ja mal sagen.
Wir haben jetzt Vorlage für so eine total geile Verschwörungstheorie geliefert und du, was machst du daraus? Nichts Fefe.
Wieso? Das ist doch aber genau die Verschwörungstheorie. Ist doch viel besser, dass die Regierung persönlich da eingesprungen ist und den Knopf gedrückt hat. Weißt du, so an der Reißleine gezogen.
Ein Koffe krieg ich ein paar ordentliche Mehl für diesen Fail.
Was laden wir hier eigentlich mal für Leute ein?
Ich hab die Geschichte wenigstens noch gewusst, ihr habt die wieder vergessen gehabt.
Ja, stimmt, das ist richtig. Hätten wir uns besser vorbereiten müssen.
Das war zu peinlich.
Naja, ist ja auch egal. Naja, und dann war noch Zierke, der hat eigentlich, der hat, wie immer, eigentlich immer dasselbe gesagt. Der war auch wieder sehr langweilig, hat man ja mal große Mühe, wach zu bleiben.
Der wirkt auch so ein bisschen als hätte Alzheimer immer, oder?
Meinst du?
Ja.
Also nicht im Sinne von irgendwie er kriegt nichts mehr zusammen, sondern so im Sinne von er spult er seine Routine ab. Und wenn eine Frage kommt, die nicht genau in seine Routine passt, dann wirkt der immer so ein bisschen hilflos.
Nee, das ist tatsächlich eher so ein Ding, der wird ja eher beschrieben als jemand, der in so der Detail-Sacharbeit aufgeht. Also das ist sein Ding, dass diese öffentlichen Sachen nicht so seine Spezialität sind. Deswegen halt diese Talking Point Replays da fährt. Es gibt so Leute, also insofern würde ich ihm jetzt mal nicht unterstellen. Aber klar war das nicht besonders beeindruckend, was er liefert hat. Und wie auch seine sonstigen Auftritte war, solche Gelegenheiten nicht besonders beeindruckend. Und schon alle, die es so kennen, dann schon mal von der Zierkeshow sprechen, weil sie schon genau wissen, was irgendwie da an Storys kommt. Naja, gut, jedenfalls.
Der BSI-Mann war noch.
BSI war noch, der im Wesentlichen eigentlich nur den technischen Sachverständigen zustimmen konnte, weil Ingenieure können ja nicht lügen.
Der hat schon ein paar Fragen gekriegt, die wir eigentlich heute auch wieder debattieren. Den haben die nämlich schon gefragt. Na, wie wollen sie das denn technisch?
Sicherstellen.
Sie haben ihn genau nach der infiltration gefragt und so. Der hat da schon sehr gestottert. Also weil er konnte ja eigentlich...
Dem tut es ja auch. Irgendwie kann der einem ja auch nur leid tun. Ich meine, viel Geld kriegen die da nicht beim BSI.
Oh, jetzt geht wieder diese Mitleidsnummer.
Mir tun die alle leid, weißt du. Ich meine, es zwingt sich natürlich keiner dazu, so einen scheiß Job anzunehmen. Aber weißt du, stell dir mal vor, du arbeitest da und sehns dich nur noch deinem Ruhestand entgegen und dann kommt jemand und sagt, hör mal, du musst jetzt diese scheiß position vor dem höchsten Gericht im Lande vertreten und sie werden dir alle peinlichen Fragen stellen, mit denen die Gegenseite kommen kann. Weißt du, und dann sitzt du da und dann fragen sie dich, also dieser Trojaner, ihr Gutachter hat gesagt, das kann man kontrollieren, wie soll das genau funktionieren? Und dann stehst du da und kannst sagen, ich habe hier keine Rede in Genehmigung.
Fefe hat viel Verständnis für die andere Seite.
Wer eben empathisch ist, versteht das.
Ich werde Altersmöde.
Na ja, und eigentlich als wir da rausgingen, nach den vielen Stunden, da haben wir eigentlich, wir wussten eigentlich schon, das fällt, das war sowieso klar, weil es so schlecht war. Die Frage war eigentlich nur, was sagen die in dem Urteil dazu? Also es war total klar, dass es verfassungswidrig ist. Anders als bei späteren Verfahren wurde es nicht so klar geworden. Also wo wir wirklich noch dem Urteil entgegen gefiebert haben, hier nicht. Also jeder hat es irgendwie gewusst. Und der Heckmann hatte auch eigentlich nichts zur Verteidigung zu sagen.
Also der Heckmann war auch, denke ich mal, der Grund, warum das Urteil auch so relativ drastisch für die Regierung ausfiel.
Also der Heckmann war der Anwalt der Regierung Nordrhein-Westfalen.
Na ja, also dann ging es halt an die Urteilsverkündung.
War eine ganze Weile später.
Wo sie dann verkündet haben, dass das Gesetz in der Angriffenform rechtswidrig ist und nichtig ist. Und das Gericht hat dann definiert, was halt geht. Und das ist halt die Sache, mit der wir jetzt ja auch wieder zu tun haben, nämlich was sind denn die Regeln, unter denen halt so ein Trojaner eingesetzt werden kann. Und sie haben eigentlich zwei mögliche Sachen definiert. Der eine, der Hauptteil, da ging es dann eben um diese sogenannte Online-Durchsuchung, also den klassischen Bundestrojaner. Und da haben sie halt extrem hohe Hürden gesetzt.
Da sollten wir vielleicht noch mal drauf zurückkommen. Also ich glaube, du steigst ja schon in das Urteil ein. Aber erst mal machen wir natürlich die Leitsitze. Der Hammer, der eigentlich zuerst kam, hat neue Grundrechte und dass sie es auch so genannt haben. Das ist ja doch sehr ungewöhnlich und passiert eigentlich nur alle, also viele Jahre Abstand. Ich glaube, da war das Urteil zu informationellen Selbstbestimmungen gerade so 24 Jahre hier oder so oder 23, 23. Also das passiert ja selten, dass sie es auch noch so nennen.
Genau, das heißt, das ist das Grundrecht auf die Vertraulichkeit und Integrität informationstechnischer Systeme. Wahlweise Computergrundrecht oder digitale Intimsphäre abgekürzt.
Die meisten, also wenn man jetzt ein bisschen guckt, hast du bei den Juristen sagen, viele Computergrundrechte, aber aus meiner Sicht fast natürlich. Naja gut, aber den langen Begriff.
Das klingt so ein bisschen, wie jeder darf einen Computer haben. Das ist kein guter Terminus.
Das war eigentlich erstmal der Hammer, dass sie, das war ja auch gleich in den ersten Minuten.
Das war auch tatsächlich der unerwartete Aspekt, wo wir also wirklich erstmal schlucken mussten.
Genau.
Vor allem mussten wir uns erstmal erkundigen, was das jetzt genau heißt, weil wir haben das ja auch noch nie gemacht.
Das lesen sie ja dann vor.
Aber also so richtig so, was passiert denn jetzt so?
Ja, da können wir noch dran erinnern, dass ich da dachte, wow.
Dann haben wir versucht, irgendwie auswendig zu lernen für die Pressearbeit danach, dass wir das irgendwie fehlerfrei sprechen können. Das ist ja bis heute nicht so leicht. Na ja, dann haben sie, was wir auch nicht richtig wussten, dass sie also einen ganz großen Teil des Urteils davor lesen. Und jetzt können wir nochmal zurückkommen auf das Stück, wo ich dich jetzt eben unterbrochen habe.
Genau. Und die Frage war, dann lassen sie es überhaupt zu? Also lassen sie halt eine Einschränkung dieses neuen Grundrechts überhaupt zu? Und wenn ja, unter welchen Voraussetzungen?
Na ja, also jeder drehte Schrank. Genau.
Und die Voraussetzungen, die sie da gezogen haben, sind halt relativ hoch. Also ist halt so, dass das halt nicht heißt, dass man überhaupt keine Online-Durchsuchung durchführen kann.
Das war natürlich auch, was die Regierungsseite dann sofort betont hat in jedem Interview, dass sie ja auch total happy sind, weil sie dürfen ja weiter online durchsuchen.
Aber die Hürden sind halt wirklich hoch. Zumindest auf dem Papier, wie es in der Praxis ist. Mal sehen. Und zum anderen gibt es auch einen ganzen Absatz zum Thema der sogenannten quellentelekommunikationsübersicht oder Quellentickerübe.
Der Begriff war ja gerade mal so ungefähr ein dreiviertel Jahr alt. Den hatten sie sich eigentlich erst vor kurzem vorher ausgedacht.
Und dabei ging es eben darum, den...
Moment, die Regierung hat sich... Also nicht das Gericht hat sich den ausgedacht, sondern als sich abzeichnete, dass das nicht so gut läuft, haben sie sich überlegt, ob sie da noch schnell irgendwie einen Winkel finden können, um da noch was zu retten. Und der Winkel war eben die QuellentKÜ, wo es gesagt hat, das ist eben zwar auch ein Trojaner, aber wir nennen ihn jetzt mal QuellentKÜ. Und die funktionalität von dem ist technisch und rechtlich eingeschränkt. Der darf nur telekommunikation abhören.
Na, das ist ein Urteil. Vorher haben sie die aber selber eigentlich schon so definiert. Sie wollten ja extra detrennen. Das haben sie dann nur bestätigt bekommen im Prinzip.
Genau, also die Idee, das so abzutrennen, kam nicht vom Gericht, sondern von der Gegenseite. Ja, also war das eigentlich die Bundesregierung oder die Regierung in der Wiese?
Na, ich kenn mich ja nicht, als ich das erste Mal lesen hab mit diesem Fragenkatalog. Könnt ihr euch erinnern, da gab es diesen großen Fragenkatalog. Das waren so, ich würde sagen, zweimal zwölf Fragen oder zweimal 15 Fragen, die sie da beantwortet hatten, wo auch erst einmal der Begriff Remote Forensic Software kam. Ach so, die Begrifflichkeit. Wusstet ihr überhaupt, wer das Wort Bundesstrojaner erfunden hat? Na? Weißt du, was du meinst? Ich weiß. Und zwar war das Peter Welchering vom Deutschlandfunk, deutschlandradio, und aufgegriffen hatet, babababam, Hartmut Pohl. Hartmut Pohl hatte in Datenschutz und Datensicherheit eine Fußnote und hat dort draufgeschrieben, zu welcher Sendung Peter Welchering diesen Begriff Bundesstrojaner erstmals aufgegriffen hätte. Die Entstehung ist eigentlich auch einigermaßen morbid, oder?
Das ist ja wohl wirklich bizarr.
Ja. Und wer hat sich die Computerwahnzause gedacht? Den Begriff?
Waren wir das?
Nee, das waren wir auch nicht.
Nee, war's nicht?
Nee, das war Gerhard Baum, der Beschwerdeführer. Der ist immer mal wichtig für die Begrifflichkeit.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Und das Remote Forensic Software ist ein unbekannter Autor.
Der ist einer von diesen Herstellern.
Cybercrime convention Begriffen, oder?
Nee, das ist einer von den Herstellern.
Ach so, ja, klingt schon so.
Kann natürlich sein.
Na gut, also jedenfalls als wir dann das Urteil in der Hand hatten und das lasen.
Weißt du noch, mit wem wir die lesen haben? Wir sind nämlich da in den Zug gehüpft und sehr schnell nach Berlin gefahren. Und mit wem saßen wir da am Speisewagen?
Mit Gerhard Baum, ne?
Mit Gerhard Baum. Wir haben also mit einem von den Beschwerdeführern zu sagen, unmittelbar danach Wort für Wort eigentlich und ganze Passagen versucht zu verstehen, was das bedeutet.
Und auch da fiel uns schon diese Geschichte zur QuellentKÜ auf.
Ja, mir fehlt dann noch eine andere Sache auf, die mich aber da können wir gleich zu kommen.
Ja, also diese QuellentKÜ, da hat das Gericht heute gesagt, ist alles besorgniserregend, wenn der Computer einmal infiltriert ist, ist irgendwie die Schwelle überschritten. Deswegen irgendwie problematisch. Aber und dann kommt so ein Absatz, der für mich immer sich immer noch so liest, als hätten sie den erst so kurz vor Schluss irgendwie eingefügt, weil er nämlich den vorhergehenden Absätzen ja so im Geist nicht so ganz entspricht, wo sie dann schrieben, also eine quellenthelekommunikation ist zulässig nach Maßgabe der normalen telekommunikationsüberwachung, wenn durch technische und rechtliche Maßnahmen sichergestellt ist, dass keine über die telekommunikation hinausgehenden Daten erhoben und ausgeleitet werden.
Ich darf übrigens bestätigen, dass Frank das aus dem Kopf macht und hier nicht ablässt. Das war eine Reißleine. Ja genau, das ist, was da steht. Das ist fast ein Zitat gewesen.
Das wirkt auf mich immer so, als wenn die da noch einen Einlauf gekriegt haben von den Darfsträgern. Guck mal, wenn ihr das jetzt verbietet, dann haben wir hier die Terroristen im Land und ihr seid schuld.
Na so geht es, glaube ich, beim Gericht nicht.
Nein, aber so liest sich das einfach. Der Kontext passt nicht.
Da es eines der Urteile war, wo ja auch die Richter durchaus unterschiedlicher Meinung waren im Detail, würde ich schon davon ausgehen, dass es am Ende halt irgendwie ein Ergebnis eines Kompromiss geben und Nehmens war.
Dann kann man ja vielleicht auch mal erzählen, wie das eigentlich so läuft. Es gibt ja immer einen Berichterstatter in diesem Fall, war das Hoffmann Riem, der danach, also war sein letztes großes Urteil sozusagen. Und tatsächlich Hoffmann Riem und seine Mitarbeiter schreiben dann auch das Urteil. Das ist ja, so ist es verteilt. Und währenddessen finden natürlich hier Debatten statt.
Na gut, also jedenfalls, das war der eine Punkt, der uns schon, ja, so, das war einfach merkwürdig und haben wir dreimal gelesen.
Und da war auch damals im Grunde schon klar, dass jetzt eine Frage der Zeit, bis das passiert. Und dann werden sie das bestimmt nicht hinkriegen. Natürlich. Aber also unsere Voraussage war nicht nur, das wird jetzt passieren, sondern da werden sie bestimmt verkacken. Und dann haben wir so.
Das ist richtig.
Oder waren wir eigentlich von Tag eins aus sicher, dass da irgendwie das können sie nicht hinkriegen.
Jemand hat ja, ich hab das gerade vorhin erzählt, jemand hat ja gerade noch den alten Talk, den Andreas Burk, Fefe und ich zu mir. Ich glaube, das war nach dem Urteil, oder? Nein, das war nach der Anhörung.
Ach, der Anhörung, ja.
Ja, genau. Also muss das Ende 2007 gewesen sein. Da haben wir gesagt, wir haben keine Mythen. Wir haben auch keine Wahrheiten, aber gute Mythen, hieß er, glaube ich. Und da haben wir wohl deutlich aufgerufen am Ende. Ich konnte mich jetzt auch nicht mehr erinnern, aber jemand hat es wieder getwittert. Schickt uns nochmal, was ihr habt.
Na, wir haben mehrfach dazu aufgerufen.
Na ja, aber da war es halt das erste Mal. Da war doch gerade noch neu. Wir waren 2007.
Also das gilt auch nach wie vor.
Ja, klar.
Wer bei sich irgendwelche staatliche Trojaner-Software findet oder?
Aber keine andere, bitte. Wir brauchen keine freilaufenden, nur die staatlichen, bitte.
Ja, nun ja.
Das war dann noch ein zweiter Punkt, den ich damals wirklich bis heute auch unrichtig finde. Denn bezogen haben sie sich ja immer auch in der Begründung auf diesen juristischen Terminus, der heißt also der Kernbrech der privaten Lebensgestaltung. Naja, und der kommt ja eigentlich aus dem Urteil zum großen Lauschangriff. Da haben sie ja gerade Begründete gehabt, also in die Schlafzimmer darf man nicht mehr tanzen, reinhören, weil man auch nur Gefahr laufen könnte, dass man was aufzeichnet, was höchstpersönlicher Natur sei. Das heißt, und das steht auch so drin, dass es da einen absolut geschützten Kernbereich gab. Und das ist mit dem Urteil zu einer Durchsuchung aufgehoben worden oder aufgereicht worden. Weil nämlich danach klar war, dass man sehr wohl was aus diesem Kernbereich aufnehmen darf, dass man es dann nur nicht verwerten darf. Aber für mich ist es halt ein Unterschied, ob ich es schon aufzeichnen darf.
Der Hintergrund dabei war, dass die Regierung argumentiert hat, dass gerade schlimme Terroristen anfangen, diesen Kernbereichsschutz auszunutzen, indem sie halt in ihren Schlafzimmern, in ihre Tagebücher, in ihren Schlafzimmern halt die schlimmen Bombenbaupläne reinschreiben. Also das war halt so sozusagen die Begründung, mit der sie versucht haben, diesen Kernbereichsschutz auszuhöhlen.
Da wird das Weltbild auch so klar, was?
Diesen Kernbereichsschutz auszuhöhlen. Naja, nun, nachdem die Ermittlungsbehärden da doch irgendwie mit weniger blauem Auge als eigentlich erwartet hatten, raus kamen, haben sie dann ja offenbar angefangen, eine Ausschreibung zu machen. Zur Tat zu schreiten und eine Ausschreibung zu machen.
Fefe, könntest du auf uns chatten? Man hört ja durch.
Ach weiß, ich tipp ganz leise.
Also im Vergleich zu sonst tippt er wirklich leise.
Ja, aber überleg dir doch mal, wenn jemand auswertet, kann er auch sehen, was er tippt hat.
Na ja, Software fürs Passwort nicht meins. Na gut, also jedenfalls die Ermittlungsbehörden haben dann natürlich angefangen, Software in Auftrag zu geben und dann gab es die ersten Leaks dazu. Nämlich die Sachen mit dem Papier von dem Angebot.
Und der Leistungsbeschreibung.
Und der Leistungsbeschreibung von der Firma Digitask.
Das lief irgendwie, ich glaube, in einem Wiki der Piratenpartei und dann bei Netzpolitik, wenn ich mich recht erinnere.
Genau und dann irgendwann noch bei WikiLeaks.
Ja, aber das war viel später. Ja, schon, aber das war glaube ich schon mal wegzensiert werden sollte.
Erstens, die haben noch eine Hausdurchsuchung gehabt, eine illegale, die Piraten.
Ja, aber das war glaube ich noch später. Das war deutlich später. Das hatte schon niemand mehr da wartet.
Ja, also jedenfalls wollten sie dieses Angebot weghaben. Also es war ihnen offensichtlich unangenehm. Und dass sie damit wieder mal den Fehler begangen haben, durch so eine Hausdurchsuchung quasi die Echtheit zu bestätigen, ist dann offensichtlich beim bayerischen LKA noch nicht so richtig durchgedrungen gewesen. Weil wir hoffen, dass sie irgendwie dieses Mal ein bisschen schlauer sind.
Schon zu spät.
Die besten der besten.
Na gut, also der...
Es tut uns ja auch so ein bisschen leid, also mir zumindest.
Du hast einfach zu großes Herzf Ach ja. Ja, also diesem Angebot, was für den heutigen Kontext noch ein paar Mal relevant sein wird, wurde relativ detailliert beschrieben, wie so eine quellen-telekommunikationsüberwachungssoftware aussieht und was die Leistungsbeschreibung dafür ist. Und da ging es halt genau darum, dass die in der Lage ist, Skype abzuwöhnen. Das ganze Ding lief unter dem Namen Skype Capture Unit und das in der Lage ist, Bildschirmfotos zu machen. Und das hier war sogar beinhaltete die Anmietung eines Servers im Ausland.
War nicht noch ein Keylogger dabei?
Ein Keylogger kann sein, ja.
Das war damals auch nicht dabei. Und der ausländische Proxy, das war eine Empfehlung.
Ja, genau.
Wie man das so macht bei Angeboten, da machst du mal noch ein paar Punkte optional.
Das ist ja immer ein Punkt, über den wir ja noch mal reden müssen. Wir müssen noch mal über den Amis sauber reden.
In dem Punkt, also in dem Angebot ging es dann, beziehungsweise das Dokument, was da liegte, ging es halt primär darum, wer denn jetzt dafür bezahlen muss. Digitask vermietet irgendwie diese Software laut diesem Angebot für 2.500-3.000 Euro im Monat, also relativ viel Geld pro Abhörmaßnahme.
Das ist eigentlich ja genau das Pro-Maßnahme, oder?
Und du kannst das auch nicht kaufen, das kannst du nur mieten. Also die haben sich schon gedacht, naja, so viele Anbieter wird es ja nicht geben. Können wir ja mal die vertraglichen Rahmenbedingungen dichten.
Gibt es mal ein Computergeschäftsmodell, oder wie?
Interessant daran ist natürlich, wenn man sich das mal ökonomisch anguckt, nehmen wir mal irgendwie 3.000 Euro im Monat und sie sagen, sie stellen das Pro-Abhörmaßnahme separat zusammen.
Ist ein Wachstumsmarkt der Terrorismus.
Durchschnittlich läuft so eine Maßnahme irgendwie drei Monate oder sechs Monate, also irgendwie mal 3.000 Euro. Ist nicht so viel Geld eigentlich. Also wenn man halt irgendwie sagt, der wird speziell für die Maßnahme geschrieben, da wird eigentlich schon klar, dass das nicht geht.
Wir hatten eine Hausnummer für die Summe, die entstammt, ich glaube, einer kleinen Anfrage, der Antwort auf eine Kleine Anfrage. Damals war die Rede für so einen individualisierten Bundestrojaner 200.000 K.
Euro.
Ja. 200.000 K, was irgendwie für eine...
Ja, warte, oh, ja, also ich meine 200.000 Euro, also 200.000 K.
Was halt für eine individualisierte weaponized Trojaner-Software ja durchaus eher eine realistische Größe auch noch ist.
Ja, das fand ich eigentlich auch. Also da haben alle so gedacht, naja, das könnte man sich vorstellen.
So, die Task vermietet jetzt diesen Kram für 3000 Euro im Monat. Daraus folgt schon der Aufwand, den die da eigentlich für treiben können.
Den haben wir ja nur hoch gesehen, den Aufwand.
Genau. Ja, jetzt dann mal irgendwie fast forward zur Jetztzeit.
Oh, wir machen wieder einen Zeitsprung. Okay, Frank ist halt ein bisschen komisch, oder?
Wieso?
Ach, naja.
Ich richte mich eigentlich nur nach dem Pad.
Na, ich bin ja ein geflüssentlicher Hörer und dann macht ihr ja auch nicht so Zeitsprünge. Aber gut, der Zeitsprung geht wohin?
Na zu vor ein paar Monaten.
Na, so lange wir immer nur nach vorne springen, ist doch gut.
Ja, bin doch nicht sicher.
Eine Rückblende machen wir gleich noch.
Oh, verstehe. Jetzt in ein paar Monaten? Also zu welchem Zeitpunkt, was passiert da?
Als die ersten Platten bei uns eintrudelten.
Ja, naja.
Also wir haben das ja mehrfach angesagt.
Es ist ja auch schon wieder spät, wenn man sich mal überlegt, wann die angefangen haben, sie einzusetzen. Eigentlich haben wir relativ spät Platten bekommen, oder?
Ja, also wir wissen, dass es seit 2007 oder 2008 eingesetzt wird. Und die Platten trudelten jetzt dann erst.
Na, es gibt Fälle. Der erste Fall, der wirklich bekannt wurde, war ja der Fall der Spiegelredakteurin in Afghanistan.
Ja, aber das war im BND-Trojan.
Ja, aber der war der erste, der aus meiner Sicht öffentlich debattiert wurde.
Ja.
Also würde ich jedenfalls mal sagen, ja.
Ja, und die hatten auch zugegeben, dass der BND da auch irgendwelche Afghanen infiltriert hatte, aber das hatte niemanden zu sagen.
Na, da war auch noch ein Ministerium beteiligt in Afghanistan.
Ja, genau. Irgendwann haben sie da infiltriert.
Ich hab vergessen, auch ein Ministerium.
Ja, das hat keine Sorge.
Okay, sie hat niemanden interessiert, da dachten alle, das ist schon...
Doch, das war schon ein Skandal. Bei uns sind die Journalisten besonders geschützt.
Nicht aus datenschutzrechtlicher irgendwie.
Na hör mal, Pressefreiheit.
Ja, nicht die Journalisten-Seite meine ich jetzt, sondern dass sie daneben noch irgendwelche Ministerien in Afghanistan infiltriert haben.
Ja, aber das fiel in die Zeit, wo ihr schon irgendwie drei Untersuchungsausschüsse, also BND-Untersuchungsausschüsse irgendwie im Gange waren.
Oh ja, die werden bestimmt in ihren Schuhen gezittert haben, die BNDler. Oh nein, noch ein Ausschuss. Wir sind so gut wie tot. Na ja, also eigentlich, was ich interessant fand an diesem digitales Ding, ist, dass ja mein Gedankenmodell zu der Zeit eigentlich nicht war, das kaufen sie jetzt irgendwo, sondern das macht jetzt der BND in Amtshilfe.
Das klang so eine Weile her eben.
Und deswegen hat mich das schon überrascht, dass die da jetzt den freien Markt befragt haben.
Den Billigmarkt.
Das wirkte so ein bisschen, na ja, billig.
Herrgott, was Sie meine für 3000 Euro?
Ich meine, von der Qualität das Kode mal Rückschlüsse lässt auf, wie gut bezahlt die Leute gewesen sein werden, dann ist das also so billig. Da ist es schon noch profitrande. Aber jedenfalls, es wirkte damals auf mich so ein bisschen so, als ginge es da gar nicht darum, jetzt tatsächlich den Trojaner einzukaufen, sondern es ging darum, so Kompetenzgerange, wir haben auch einen Trojaner, so wirkte das. Die eigentlichen Maßnahmen, nahm ich also noch lange an, würden dann schon mit Qualitätssoftware vom BND, wenn ich das jetzt mal so als kleinen Insiderwitz ablassen kann.
Hast du da eine Qualitätsvermutung?
Nein, aber das können wir vielleicht auch noch kurz erläutern. Also BND gilt nicht gerade als die Leuchte unter den Diensten.
Ich meine, es gibt immer Ausnahmen, insofern wir wissen nicht.
Eigentlich haben wir ja gehofft, dass wir ein BND Trojaner kriegen.
Ich glaube, das Diuretzko-Buch hättet ihr doch auch schon mal.
Ja, natürlich. Also eigentlich haben wir gehofft, dass wir so ein BND Trojaner kriegen und dass wir da noch irgendwie Spuren von irgendwelchen Einsätzen im Ausland finden oder so. Na gut, dann haben wir halt diese...
Wir sollten für die Zukunft hoffen.
Ja, also es kann ja noch kommen. Das Jahr ist noch jung.
Jedenfalls rudeten dann die Festplatten bei uns ein. Na ja, das Interessante war eigentlich... Also, ich glaube, das Erste Interessante war, dass wir überhaupt was gefunden haben.
Ja, bis...
Also, das war für mich eher überraschend. Ich habe gedacht, das können wir bestimmt zu den Akten legen. Also, löschen werden sie können, habe ich gedacht.
Vor allem weiß man das ja nicht, wenn ein Typ zu dir kommt und sagt, ich bin hier infiltriert und die Erdstrahlen von den Orbitalen irgendwie Gehirnwäsche, Kontrollanüge...
Weißt du, wie viel wir in diesen Tagen davon haben? Ja, ich weiß.
Also, was im Moment bei uns aufschlägt von Leuten, die sich überwacht und infiltriert fühlen. Jedenfalls, also nur weil jemand beim CCC eine Platte einschickt, da machten wir uns eigentlich noch nicht viel Hoffnung, dass da tatsächlich irgendwas drauf ist.
Also, die Wege waren jetzt zwar nicht... Die wollen wir ja hier nicht so näher besprechen, wie die nun zu uns kamen, aber...
Das ist kein Selbstläufer jedenfalls, dieser Übergang. In diesem Fall war doch was drauf. Es war nicht mehr im Pfeilsystem, aber es war halbgesagt.
Also, ich fand's wirklich überraschend. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass die das nicht laschen können. Das hätte ich einfach nicht vermutet.
Ja, und wie wir dann halt hinterher gesehen haben bei der Analyse, ist halt die Selbstmordroutine des Torhörers einfach schlicht nicht in der Lage, so zu löschen, dass man nicht mit Voransicht-Tools die Sachen wieder runterkriegt, wenn nach dem Löschen halt nicht noch viele Daten auf die Platte geschrieben werden.
Ja klar, also wenn es irgendwie überschrieben wird, dann ist ja klar. Also ich glaube, wir brauchen jetzt auch in diesem Podcast nicht erklären, dass löschen nicht löschen ist oder so. Frank, mach doch mal einen Kurve-Verrat zu, was ist löschen auf einem Computer?
Haben wir doch schon mal einen Kurve-Verrat.
Haben wir schon, brauchen wir nicht. Also der...
Ihr seid ja faul.
Also jedenfalls fanden wir dann halt auf dem Computer, nachdem die gelöschten Dateien wiederhergestellt wurden, fanden sich halt ein paar Sachen, die halt eher merkwürdig waren. Unter anderem halt eine DLL, also eine Dynamisch-Ladbare-Library und einen Kernel-Treiber, die beide gelöscht waren und den...
Also gelöscht...
Als gelöscht markiert.
Als gelöscht markiert. Und dann haben sich halt ein paar Leute an die Analyse gemacht und halt an die Details. Vielleicht kann Fefe ja mal erzählen, wie man so eine...
Ja, Fefe erzähl doch mal. Genau.
Das ist doch der tägliche Brot.
So die Grundprinzipien des Bewusst-Engineerings.
Ah, naja. Also als Erstes muss man ja finden, wie das Ding überhaupt geladen wird. Normalerweise so ein Toyaner, der installiert sich irgendwie oder überhaupt irgendwelche Mailware installiert sich normalerweise im System irgendwie. Wir haben es hier mit Windows zu tun gehabt. Das ist auch die übliche Lebensumgebung für Mailware. Und da gibt es halt so eine Handvoll von Sachen, wie man sich installieren kann. Üblicherweise so eine Autostartliste. Und da haben wir halt reingeguckt. Und da trägt sich das Teil ein. Das war schon mal das erste danach. Was man als erstes macht, wenn man die Datei hat, ist, dass man eben nach ASCII-Strings darin sucht. Irgendwelche Zeichenketten, die aussehen wie Sachen, die man schon irgendwie zuordnen kann. Und so ein Registry-Pfad ist eine Sache, die erkennt man. So ein Pfad im Satellsystem ist, was das erkennt man. So ein Gerätetreibername ist, was erkennt man. Und das sieht man halt. Das haben wir auch in dieser DLL gefunden.
Du sagst noch ein bisschen was zu den Tours, die man in der normalerweise schon zu Hilfe nimmt.
Also das erste, was man macht, ist tatsächlich in Strings. Also das ist einfach nur Suchen nach ASCII-Ketten. Danach disassembliert man. Aber was ich den Punkt, den ich davor noch machen wollte, ist moderne Mailware ist an sich verschlüsselt. Also jetzt nicht wirklich verschlüsselt, weil man muss ja sich selbst entschlüsseln können. Aber zumindest hat es einen Loader davor, ist irgendwie verschleiert und hat Maßnahmen, damit man es nicht debuggen kann.
Das müssen wir eigentlich der Presse auch nochmal klären, weil das haben wir jetzt immer weggelassen.
Wir haben das immer weggelassen, weil wir denen eigentlich keine Anleitung geben wollen, wie man es besser macht. Aber normalerweise kommt man mit so einem Strings-Ding nicht weit, weil einfach die, die natürlich wissen und sich da irgendwie packen und Anti-Debugging drin haben und so ein Kram. Das ist ja alles nicht der Fall. Das heißt, schon beim Strings.
Also so viel Mühe haben sie nicht gemacht.
Im Grunde hat man schon beim ersten Strings gesehen, das ist ein Trojaner und der besteht aus zwei Komponenten und die haben jeweils den Pfad der anderen drin. Das ist ja schon mal ganz besonders schlau. Also das heißt, da haben wir auch ziemlich sofort gesehen, irgendwie das ist der andere Teil, ein Kernmodul, ein User-Space-Teil. Und dann kann man zum Beispiel IDA benutzen, das ist der Disassembler der Wahl zum Reversen. Und da lädt man dann eben diese Sachen rein und dann kriegt man so ein Disassemblert. Und da stehen dann die ganzen Symbole nicht mehr drin aus dem Quellcode. Und es ist auch nicht mehr C, sondern es ist dann eben Assemblercode. Aber das kann man trotzdem rekonstruieren.
Also das war übrigens kein C-Code, den wir da hatten. Nur, dass die Hörer nicht denken.
Nein. Das Problem ist halt, dass so eine Hochsprache wie C oder C++ oder andere Sprachen, die werden eben auf Maschinencode abgebildet und es ist keine 1 zu 1 Abbildung. Deswegen ist das kein Selbstläufer. Aber man kann aus dem Maschinencode so grob die Struktur von dem Code darüber zurückbasteln. Das muss man sich wie so einen Puzzle vorstellen.
Und auch, welche funktion was aufruft, ist ja auch immer richtig.
Das ist gerade so ein Punkt, der hier ein bisschen schwieriger war, weil das eben C++ war. Und da ist es eben keine direkten Aufrufe in vielen Stellen, sondern es geht über irgendwelche virtuellen funktionstabellen. Also das ist kein Selbstläufer, aber das ist eben die Kompetenz eines Reverse-Engineers, dass er so was zurückbasteln kann. Das dauert ein bisschen. Wir haben da auch ein bisschen Aufwand reingesteckt.
Und sechs, sieben Wochen waren das schon insgesamt.
Na gut, aber jetzt nicht Vollzeit.
Nein, nein. Schätz mal, wenn du das Vollzeit hinkriegen willst. Also ich würde mal sagen, drei Tage hast du das, wenn du nur das arbeitest.
Nee, ist schon ein bisschen mehr.
Meinst du ein bisschen mehr?
Na ja, in einer Woche hat man das durch.
In der Woche ist vielleicht realistisch. Aber ich meine, wenn man es halt irgendwie nach Feierabend macht, sechs, sieben Wochen waren das bestimmt.
Ja, also wir haben jetzt aber auch keine wirkliche Not gehabt.
Ich weiß nicht, ich überlege, wenn ich dir eine professionelle Firma gebe, oder da Geld um den Tisch lege, haben die mir in drei, vier Tagen gemacht.
Ja, aber naja, die kann man nicht.
Das würde ich erwarten.
Dann sind wir mit mehreren Leuten machen.
Na ja, klar.
Na gut, aber alleine.
Also machbar ist es, ja. Wir haben jetzt nicht furchtbar auf die Tube gedrückt.
Na ja, wir haben eigentlich erst angefangen, wirklich auf die Tube zu drücken, nachdem klar war, dass es da einige da an Brisanz gibt. Und nachdem die ersten funktionalitäten so rauskamen, dann ging es eigentlich erst los.
Also man konnte an dem Trojaner sehen, was sehr ungewöhnlich ist für Mailware, dass der die Skype-API benutzt. Also dieser Trojaner meldet sich bei Skype an und sagt Hallo, ich bin ein Skype-Modul, ich würde gerne mithören.
Weißt du, ich weiß gar nicht, warum du das so ungewöhnlich findest. Diese Menge an kriminellen spionagessoftware, die einfach nur voyeuristisch Skype-Telefonate mithören will, ist dir wohl entgangen?
Ja, in der Tat ist mir entgangen, gibt es nämlich nicht. Denn andere Trojaner, die mithören, legen keinen Wert darauf, beim Anfang der telekommunikation mithören, sondern die gehen einfach zum audio-device und hören alles mit.
Das ist ein Argument, aber bei mir sind immer diese ganzen...
Nein, aber ich meine, das ist ein wichtiges Argument, weil das eins unserer technischen Hauptindizien dafür ist, dass ich um mein Regierungs-Trojaner...
Ich habe Geschirrz.
Ich will das hier nur sicherstellen, falls wir homoerlose Hörer haben, das weiß man nicht.
Ah, homoerlose Hörer haben wir nicht.
Wir haben doch keine... Naja, wir könnten Bundes-Trojaner-Abstreiter haben. Es gibt ja welche.
Das ist aber dann deren Problem, wenn sie tönen.
Ich hab so eine heiße Trojaner.
Leugnaya, Leugnaya. Naja, also um das nochmal ein bisschen auszuführen. Normalerweise, wenn man Trojaner ist und der möchte gern mithören bei Skype, dann ist einem das doch scheißegal, ob man auch irgendwie das Rollstuhl davor hört oder nicht. Dann geht man einfach ans audio-device und hört mit. Oder man klingt sich in die Sound-Infrastruktur von Windows ein. Da gibt es verschiedene Pfade, die da genommen werden. Aber man geht jedenfalls nicht zu Skype. Denn was Skype macht, wenn man dieses API benutzt, ist ein Pop-Up. Und wollen sie denn wirklich dieser Anwendung durch diese obskure Anwendung pippen? Und da sieht man schon, dass der infektionsweg für sowas ein bisschen trickreich ist. Da muss also entweder physischer Zugang da sein und der Typ, der das installiert, macht halt das Pop-Up weg. Oder die haben noch eine andere Routine, um sich da einzuklingen.
Also was man dazu sagen muss, diese Skype-Abhörnummer haben wir uns da drin nicht besonders intensiv angeguckt, weil es eben klar war, dass das eine funktion ist, die ja gerichtlich genehmigt ist.
Und die geht auch, das wussten wir ja schon.
Genau, dass sie geht, wussten wir halt zu dem Zeitpunkt. Was aber interessanter war, waren eben die anderen funktionen, die wir noch da drin gefunden haben.
Der Punkt ist halt, wenn du deine skype-funktionalität findest, dann ist das einfach mal eine rote Fahne. Hier haben wir einen Trojaner, der ist interessant.
Ein Behörden-Trojaner. Aber erzählt das mal der Presse, damit hätte ich auch schon Schwierigkeiten. Verstehen die mal jemand?
Ja, natürlich. Deswegen haben wir ja diese Sendung hier. Da können wir das in Ruhe erläutern. Also normale Trojaner, die mithören, scheißen darauf, ob jetzt ein Telefonat angefangen hat oder nicht und hören einfach alles mit. Und dieser Trojaner geht extra Aufwand ein, und zwar gar nicht mal trivialen Aufwand, um von Skype tatsächlich mitzukriegen, wann jetzt das Telefonat anfängt.
Also sie haben sich schon Mühe gegeben, diesen Teil der Software so zu schreiben, dass er gesetzlich konform sein könnte.
Der einzige Grund, warum man sowas tun wollen würde, ist, wenn man gesetzliche Vorschrift hat, dass man nur das Telefonat mitschneiden darf. Einen anderen Grund gibt es dafür eigentlich nicht. So, das ist eine der wichtigen technischen Medizin, warum wir uns relativ sicher waren, dass es ein Regierungstrojaner ist. Und dann haben wir eben mal den Rest angeguckt. Und da war natürlich jetzt der Kontext gegeben von dem Verfassungsgericht, die ja gesagt haben, es muss technisch vorgesorgt sein, dass man damit keine Sachen machen kann, die nicht hier in dieser Liste drinstehen. Und in der Liste stand nicht drin, dass man Mailware nachladen darf.
Und das gilt natürlich nicht nur für die Quantik, sondern auch für den Bundestrojaner-TM, also die richtige volle Online-Durchsuchung. Also wir haben ja jetzt ein bisschen unterschieden. Also es ist ja jetzt in der Presse ganz wenig unterschieden worden. Aber ich glaube, das haben wir jetzt schon ein paar Mal erklärt, dass es zwei unterschiedliche Dinge sind. Aber verboten wäre das für beide, also das Nachladen.
Ja, gut, also Bundestrojaner, ich bin auch so ein bisschen schuldig. Ich habe in meinem Blog die Begriffe durcheinander geworfen.
Ja, das haben aber alle. Hanne, da bist du nicht der Einzige.
Und zwar durchaus absichtlich, weil das eben ein Begriff ist, den die Leute kennen.
Oh, jetzt hat er es wieder hin, als wäre das Absicht. Das macht er jedes Mal.
Das war auch Absicht. Bundestrojaner kennen die Leute. Computerwanze ist so ein Ding.
Wir sollten nochmal kurz erklären.
Computerwanze, was ist denn das? Bitte hör mal.
Wir sollten vielleicht nochmal erklären, wie die...
Nee, warte mal, wir sollten erstmal sagen, was das für eine Auswirkung hatte, dass die Leute alle über Bundestrojaner geredet haben. Das hat nämlich die Dementis beeinflusst, die jetzt von der Regierung kamen. Die haben versucht sich da...
Moment, warte mal, lass uns bitte erst mal kurz durcherklären, was der technische Teil davon ist. Dann kommen wir zu diesen ganzen PR-Spielen hinterher, weil die sind interessant für sich.
Durchaus unterhaltsam.
Genau. Gut, also was wir getan haben, wir haben uns halt angeguckt, was für Kommandos nimmt das Ding an. Da findet man dann halt so ein großes Case Statement. Das heißt also, wenn irgendwie dieses Kommando reinkommt, dann macht dieses. Und das Ding hat halt insgesamt, also frisst halt 18 Kommandos und die sind halt numeriert von 1 bis 18. Das heißt also, das hat sich hin und schickt dann eine 1 hin und der macht das Kommando 1 und dann schickt dann eine 14 hin und der macht das Kommando 14. So und die, wo wir dann so ein bisschen verblüfft waren, also alle, die da eigentlich sich in dieses Bein revertieft haben, war, alle, die sozusagen zum ersten Mal da durchguckt haben, haben erst mal nach der Entschlüsselung für die Kommandos gesucht. Also nach der funktion, die halt einfach die Kommandos entschlüsselt, weil wir, wie selbstverständlich natürlich davon ausgegangen waren, dass die Kommandos, die diesen Trojaner regeln, müssen doch verschlüsseln sein.
Nein, nicht nur verschlüsselt, auch signiert.
Und auch signiert.
Also das ist ja noch schlimmer. Ja, Verschlüsselung ist ja eine Sache, aber gut. Der Punkt ist halt, wir haben ja durchaus Verschlüsselung gefunden in dem Trojaner.
Das war auch ziemlich das Erste.
Aber keine Entschlüsselung.
Genau, es gab halt keine Entschlüsselung. Es gab nur Verschlüsselung in diesem Trojaner. Und das war halt irgendwie so, also das ist mehrere Leuten passiert, die nach der Entschlüsselung irgendwie angefangen haben, erst mal diese entschlussfunktion gesucht und erst mal irgendwie zu verstehen, wie das Command Passing funktioniert. Und die war nicht da.
Und hier muss man mal so einen Hacker erklären. Wenn ein Hacker sich das ansieht und findet die funktion nicht und der weiß, das ist eine Mailware, dann denkt sich der Hacker, boah, die müssen ja schlau gewesen sein. Die haben das bestimmt irgendwie versteckt. Das finde ich jetzt. Und so haben wir also durchaus Wochen damit verbracht, diese Scheiße zu suchen.
Na nicht Wochen.
Na ja, aber also, wenn man addiert, wenn man die ganzen Leute addiert, die geguckt haben, dann kommt er durchaus, also jedenfalls war halt nicht da. Und deswegen haben wir uns das auch nicht nehmen lassen, im Reporter so ein bisschen gehässig draufzuklopfen.
Ja, wir haben jetzt so ein bisschen Vorwürfe gekriegt.
Okay, lass mal ein bisschen Dix bleiben. So, also das Ding nimmt also Commandos an und führt die halt einfach aus. Und die Commandos, die wir gefunden haben, sind halt so die, die man erwarten würde. Das Ding macht halt eine skype-interception. Das Ding macht Screenshots. Das Ding hat eine bildschirm-streaming-funktionalität, also wo man halt mit niedriger Auflösung den Inhalt des gerade im Vordergrund befindlichen Bildschirmfensters gestreamt bekommt.
Also so eine Art, wenn nennt man das, Screencast.
Genau, ein Screencast mit niedriger Aufgelösten JPEGs, wo man sich dann noch sehr genau vorstellen kann, wie einfach dann so der Arbeitsablauf aussieht. Nämlich der sitzt einer vor diesem Fenster, guckt dem beim Webbrowser benutzen zu und immer wenn es interessant wird, macht er halt high-res Bildschirmfotos. Was man dazu sagen muss, ist dieser gesamte Trojaner hält keiner der State. Das heißt, er hat keine funktionen, die ihn zum Beispiel über einen Reboot hinaus noch informationen beinhaltet. Das heißt also alle informationen, die er braucht an konfigurationen, sind hardcoded. Also zum Beispiel die IP-Adresse des Command- und Control-Servers, die Portnummer, der String, mit dem er sich anmeldet und sagt, wer er ist, ist alles hardcoded.
Sag doch mal, was ein Control- und Command-Server ist.
Das haben wir auch gerne gesprochen.
Das Ding telefoniert halt permanent nach Hause und benutzt dazu ab dem Zeitpunkt, wo der Rechner an ist.
Das ist so eine Militärbegrifflichkeit eigentlich ursprünglich, die dann bei Botnetzen gelandet ist und deswegen haben wir das auch benutzt, weil das ja eigentlich im Grunde ist es ja ein Botnetz. Wir haben also eine Kiste in Amerika irgendwo stehen, ob das jetzt ein Proxy ist oder vielleicht kann man da auch irgendwie sich per Desktop einwählen oder so, das wissen wir jetzt nicht. Aber der Punkt ist von dieser Kiste aus, werden halt die ganzen Trojaner kontrolliert, die da in der Wildnis rumlaufen und sowas nennt man eben...
Verbunden werden die Deutschen, aber vielleicht auch andere, wir wissen es nicht.
Na ja, wahrscheinlich werden die deutschen Trojaner da auch von ausländischen Diensten verangesteuert. Jedenfalls, das nennt man halt im Militärjargon, nennt man das eben Command- und Control-Server, das ist eben die Kommandozentrale, die Leitzentrale würde man vielleicht bei der Feuerwehr oder so sagen. Und da kommt diese Begrifflichkeit her. Das heißt, wir haben eine IP und die steht nicht in Deutschland, von da kommen die Kommandos und das ist ja an sich schon mal ein Problem.
Dass man dazu sagen muss, wir haben halt mehrere Trojaner-Varianten und bei einem davon ist die IP in den USA und bei anderen Samples werden zum Beispiel auch deutsche Server benutzt. Das heißt, wir sehen da halt auch schon eine gewisse Varietät in den unterschiedlichen Anwendungen von diesen Trojanern. Und dieser Server in den USA wird also wahrscheinlich dafür benutzt, halt die Sachen entsprechend zum Beispiel diesen Digitask-Angebot, die wir eben genau davon gesprochen haben, den Server im Ausland zur Verschleimung der IP-Adresse zu benutzen, halt dann wieder hierher geleitet. Und diese fernsteuerfunktion, also dass das Ding praktisch live ferngesteuert wird, weist auch noch mal sehr deutlich darauf hin, dass es sich also auf gar keinen Fall um einen kommerziellen Trojaner handeln kann, weil niemand, der so was kommerziell macht, würde sich so einen, also so einen Aufwand leisten.
Den Personalaufwand, genau.
Du würdest es nicht permanent bedienen wollen, natürlich nicht.
Sondern du wirst das Ding halt vollautomatisieren, so dass er...
Ich hätte so was auch noch nie gesehen, was man... Also ich meine, das ist ja auch geradezu gefährlich für die Entdeckung.
Ja. Also dass man halt einfach den, den, ja, diese Live-Fernsteuerung da so einbaut, ist halt ein deutlicher Hinweis darauf, dass man so was nur tut, wenn man halt rechtliche Vorgaben in entsprechender Art hat. Naja, und dann haben wir halt weitergesucht und haben halt dieses Kommando 14 gefunden, was, wo wir, also mir ist ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen die Kindheit runtergeklappt. Weil ich war eigentlich bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, als es klar wurde, okay, da ist irgendwie ein bisschen Skype und ein bisschen Bildschirmshots drinnen und so. Dachten wir, okay, das wird jetzt, leider wird es ab jetzt langweilig, weil irgendwie die machen halt nur, was ihnen erlaubt ist. Und vielleicht finden wir noch ein paar Exploits oder ein paar Bugs, die man halt irgendwie hochnehmen kann und so, wie die Code-Qualität aussah. Und dann...
Moment, wir müssen eine Sache noch erklären. Also wir haben gesagt, der erste Pass, den man macht, ist, dass man halt die Strings betrachtet. Und da sieht man auch funktionsnamen von gefährlichen funktionen. Einer von diesen Strings wäre halt Create Process. Das ist eine windows-funktion, um ein neues Programm auszuführen. Und wenn ein Trojaner das gar nicht hat, diese funktion, dann ist der erste Gedanke, den man hat, also aber andere funktionen hat, dann denkt man sich, naja, also entweder sie haben es verschleiert oder sie rufen es nicht auf. Und wir gingen halt von letzterem aus, weil der Rest eben völlig unverschleiert war. Und dementsprechend groß war unsere Überraschung, als wir gesehen haben, dass der sich eben dieses Create-Process zur Laufzeit aus verstreuten Konstanten zusammenpopelt, in einen String tut und dann benutzt. Ja, das heißt, das ist das einzige bisschen Verschleierung, was wir in diesem Ding gesehen haben, ist eben genau diese funktion. Vielleicht finden wir noch was, aber bisher. Naja, also bisher, sag ich mal.
Ich vermute, ist das das einzige.
Das einzige, wo wirklich von Verschleierung die Rede sein kann, ist eben dieses Ding und das ist genau das, was ihnen explizit verboten wurde. Und das ist eben auch der Punkt, wo wir gesagt haben, naja, das ist kein Zufall, sondern das ist Vorsatz.
Ja, ich denke, dass es danach kam. Erst, ich bin nicht mehr sicher, in welche Reihenfolge.
Also ich weiß es halt genau, es war halt so, dass wir haben halt diese, vor dieser funktion gesessen haben, disassembliert und haben uns die angeguckt. Und da gibt es halt noch so ein Shell Execute Kommando. Und da gibt es dann halt so ein Statement, wo man, also zu einem Debugger haben halt irgendwie durchgesteppt und geguckt, irgendwie kommt es dann an, passiert dann was. Und kamen dann an den Punkt, wo es hätte eigentlich exekuten müssen, aber da gab es halt einen Compaire und der Schluck fehlt. Wenn also eine konstante 1 oder 0, hätte 1 sein sollen, war ne 0. Genau, war ne 0. Dann dachten wir, shit, haben sie offensichtlich, ist der ganz andre Codefahrt drinnen, aber ist offenbar ausgeschaltet. Und das war dann morgens um 6.00 Uhr und ich bin halt nach Hause gefahren. Und dann irgendwann so, ich war halt irgendwo auf dem Fahrrad irgendwo in der Pampa, weil irgendwie nix mehr fuhr. Und da kam dann irgendwie der Anruf, so naja, wir hätten nur mal im Debugger weiter steppen müssen, weil danach ging es halt weiter. Und danach hat sich dann halt diesen Create-Process zusammengebastelt und den halt exekutiert. Und als ich dann zu Hause war, kriegte ich dann schon die SMS irgendwie, dass irgendwie der Calculator läuft.
Also das kann man ja ein bisschen nachvollziehen, wenn man jetzt den Bericht liest, da ist ja ein Stück davon, also die Kommentierung noch drin. Also wer das Stück sucht, kann das im Bericht finden.
Genau, da gibt es dieses irgendwie ein Narf, wenn hier eine 1 stehen würde, würde es exekutiert werden. Genau. Und wenig später war dann klar, das hat exekutiert halt. Und zu dem Zeitpunkt war dann halt klar, dass das halt auch für uns eine ganz schön dicke Nummer wird, weil damit halt klar ist, dass eben die Grenzen des Verfassungsmäßig Erlaubten für einen Quellenticker-Utrojaner massiv überschritten werden.
Und für einen Bundestrojaner.
Und für einen Bundestrojaner auch. Und also um nochmal zu sagen, die Vorgabe des Gerichts war ja, dass durch rechtliche und technische Maßnahmen sichergestellt ist, dass es eben keine Überschreitung dieser Vorgaben gibt. Naja, und gut, dann ab da war dann halt primär halt das Ding halt nochmal weiter erkunden. Dann wurde halt die Steuersoftware dafür geschrieben. Also wir haben eine eigene Steuersoftware entwickelt. Aber relativ zackig. Die halt irgendwie eine hübsches User Interface hat.
Weißt du schon, die Beschwerden darüber, dass die Apple Graphic User Interface Guidelines nicht eingehalten wurden?
Ja, die von Leuten kommen, die sonst lieber alle direkt auf den Mond schießen zu dem Zirkel, wie die Julis gefordert haben.
Naja, egal. Also wir vermuten mal, dass unser User Interface besser aussieht, als das, mit dem die Beamten da arbeiten müssen.
Ja, das sieht ja so unglaublich wichtig aus.
Siehst du, jetzt wirst du auch altersmild und hast Mitleid mit den Leuten.
Ich hab da kein Mitleid mit. Das ist Häme, Fefe, Häme. Mitleid klingt anders.
Ja, aber ich hatte aber doch zu den Apple Fanboys vielleicht auch immer noch ein mildes Herz.
Wieso soll ich das tun, wenn ich schon sage, dass unser User Interface besser aussieht, als das, was die Beamten da machen müssen?
Man weiß nicht, wir haben das User Face der Beamten nicht gesehen.
Nee, aber vielleicht werden wir das ja sehen.
Also es würde mich wirklich wundern, wenn die Beamten ein vergleichbar komfortables User Interface haben.
Ja, wahrscheinlich dürfen wir.
Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Und dass da großer Lauschangriff, Klick, vorhanden ist als Button, kann ich mir auch nicht vorstellen.
Das kann ich mir schon vorstellen.
Großer Lauschangriff als Button?
Ja, also wahrscheinlich wird er irgendwie anders heißen, aber akustische Wohnraumüberwachung. Wahrscheinlich müssen deren Buttons denn länger sein. Deswegen brauchen die 16,9 Displays für die Abhörmaßnahmen. Also dann ging es halt irgendwie daran, halt irgendwie das nochmal zu vergleichen mit den anderen Trojaner-Varianten, die wir hatten, also ob da dieselben Sachen zu finden sind. Weil wir haben uns natürlich erst mal mit Beinerie von AIM angeguckt.
Also erst war der Schlüssel, der AES-Schlüssel der selbe ist?
Also die identifikation darüber, dass es halt dieselben Trojaner-Varianten sind auf den verschiedenen Platten, die wir bekommen haben, funktioniert er halt auch primär darüber, dass überall derselbe AES-Key drin ist, was auch noch so ein Ding ist, was wir uns echt an den Kopf gefasst haben, dass also die kommunikation vom Trojaner zum Server immer mit demselben Schlüssel erfolgt und dieser Schlüssel über mehrere Jahre hinweg, also wir haben Samples aus mehreren Jahren, immer derselbe ist.
Zumindest aber viele Monate. So können wir so genau eingrenzen. Wenn man zusammenrechnen ist, ist das ja was.
Über zwei Jahre der selbe Schlüssel.
Naja, die Upgrade-Kosten und so weiter, wir haben Sparmaßnahmen, das geht ja nicht.
Also die Frage halt eben, ob nun diese Software individuell pro Maßnahme zusammengestellt wird. In dem Code finden sich eine Menge tote Codefahre, die halt nicht benutzt werden. Also Sachen, die halt einfach drin sind. Also zum Beispiel ist da ein kompletter Codefahre drin, mit dem man einfach so das Mikrofon anmacht. Also eigentlich ein großer Lauschangriff. Nur der ist nicht aktiv.
Oh, der Keylogger.
So, und es gibt halt einen 90 Prozent von dem Keylogger an diesem Kernel-Treiber, aber auch der ist nicht aktiv. Das heißt also, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man kann dann so ein bisschen daraus folgern, wie wird denn so ein Trojaner eigentlich zusammengebaut? Und macht halt den Eindruck, als hätten die sich da irgendwie so einen Baukasten programmieren lassen.
Und schön die Module zusammen gesteckt.
Dann sitzt da halt nur noch so ein Hiwi, der in seinem Visual Basic Script irgendwie klickt, welche funktion jetzt da an sein soll, aber auf den Kern des Ganzen halt irgendwie keinen Einfluss mehr hat. Und so, dann ging es halt daran, den Report zu schreiben. Also halt zu dokumentieren und das Video zu machen für die präsentation, sodass wir halt zeigen können, wie unser Fernsteuer-Tool funktioniert und die Pressemitteilung zu schreiben. Und dann hab ich noch halt irgendwie den Artikel für die FAZ geschrieben, um die Sachen so allgemeinverständlich wie möglich zu machen. Und irgendwann hat uns dann die FAZ angeboten, so okay, wir können da auch den Code abdrucken. Also tatsächlich den Code, der genau dieses Execute macht. Was wir denn doch, wo wir erstmal einen Augenblick schlucken mussten. Aber das ist doch eigentlich ganz interessant.
Naja, im ersten Moment haben wir eigentlich alle lachen müssen über die Idee, dass man also auf vier, fünf Seiten den Code abdruckt. Aber natürlich, wenn man darüber nachdenkt, ist es natürlich eine geniale Idee.
Das ist ein Meilenstein.
Ja, nein, man muss sich überlegen, wie auf andere Leute Code wirkt. Das ist mythisch, das ist wie eine fremde Sprache, die, weiß ich nicht, uralt ist oder also irgendeine Aliensprache. Man versteht es nicht, aber es hat einen Einfluss auf Leben und so. Also naja.
Ja, na gut. Und dann haben wir halt den Kram rausgehauen. Und eigentlich ist ja die interessante Frage jetzt, wie ist jetzt was jetzt passiert? Und heute war nun der Tag, wo es halt anfing, richtig hektisch zu werden.
Im Prinzip, wo wir hier sitzen, kommen dauernd die neuen Nachrichten rein.
Genau. Und die...
Wir werden gleich noch ein bisschen iterieren, was da eigentlich alles passiert ist. Als wir angefangen haben aufzunehmen, sind drei Bundesländer umgekippt und haben Geständnisse abgeliefert.
Ja, also die interessante Frage war ja, wir haben ja die Sachen anonym bekommen. Und nur weil eben das ja zum Teil im Laufe einer Ermittlungsverfahren geht, deswegen wir halt nicht in der Freiheit waren, zu sagen, wo es jetzt herkommt und um welche Ermittlungsverfahren es geht.
Wir wollten tatsächlich die Informanten schützen. Das war auch so abgesprochen. Aber wenn natürlich jetzt einer der Informanten selber damit an die Öffentlichkeit geht, nun da könnten wir uns natürlich nur freuen. Denn damit ist klar, was für ein Fall ist. Dann kann man natürlich anders politisch debattieren jetzt.
Genau, also in dem Fall geht es halt darum, dass heute ein Ermittlungsverfahren, wo vom LKA Bayern-Trojaner eingesetzt wurden, also dass da offensichtlich eines der Samples herstammte, was wir untersucht haben.
Genau. Naja, das füllt halt eine Lücke, die wir zum Beispiel in dem Bericht nicht haben, weil wir ja nicht wissen konnten, wie ist der Schadcode eigentlich auf den Rechner gekommen. Und jetzt wissen wir, wenn das jetzt zu sagen, oder wir können es offiziell sagen, nämlich dass da eine Flughafenkontrolle gefaked wurde und eben da ein paar Minuten der Rechner eingezogen wurde und dann war danach die Schadstoffe ja drauf. Und später wurde der beschlagnahmt und Teile der Daten von dem Einsatz dieses Trojaners wurden benützt und da fanden sich unter anderem auch die Bitch-Shimp-Fotos.
Ein bisschen erwähnenswert ist noch, dass das kein Terrorfall war.
Nein, das ist eine Ermittlung gegen ein pharmazeutische Medikamente und Zeug-Exportierende.
Also das hat nichts mit Terror zu tun. Da geht es auch nicht um Lebensgefahr für irgendjemand, sondern das ist eigentlich keine schwere Kriminalität, wie das Verfassungsgericht angesagt hat.
Interessant ist natürlich die reaktion des Staates. Die erste reaktion des Inländischen Terms war ja erst mal zu sagen, dass es so andere Tage war, da war eine Funkstelle. Genau, wir müssen dazu sagen, wir haben uns halt im Vorfeld dieser Release ziemlich den Kopf gemacht, ob das jetzt richtig ist, was wir tun, also ob wir da möglicherweise Ermittlungsmaßnahmen kaputt machen, wie so was die Probleme sind.
Ja, wir wird ihnen vorher sagen, es war eigentlich von Anfang an klar, dass wir ihnen eine Warnfrist geben, weil wir wollten auch keine Ermittlungen stören. Also darum geht es uns ja nicht. Wir wollten ja im Prinzip eigentlich dann nur zeigen, was wir haben und nicht irgendwelche aktuellen Ermittlungen irgendwie unterbinden und uns auch nicht vorwerfen lassen. Das war eigentlich klar, wir haben nur bei der Frist überlegt.
Man muss ja dazu sagen, wir wussten ja nicht, wo die jetzt herkommen. Das heißt, es hätte auch tatsächlich ein Terrorfall sein können. Das war nicht unsere intention jetzt hier, das BKA am Arbeiten zu hindern. Nachher fliegt der Bundestag in die Luft, darum ging es uns nicht. Aber selbst wenn das ein Terrorfall gewesen wäre, dann muss er sich trotzdem an die Schranken vom Verfassungsgericht halten. Das heißt, selbst dann wäre das richtig gewesen, was wir gemacht haben. Wir können ja mal sagen, wie viel Vorwarnung wir denen gegeben haben. Das waren irgendwie so zwei Tage oder 36 Stunden?
36 Stunden. Also wir haben 36 Stunden mit Burkhard Hirsch geredet. Und der hat 36 Stunden vor unser Release des Bundesinvestorium auf entsprechender, fast höchster Stelle informiert, um denen halt noch die Gelegenheit zu geben, halt irgendwie entsprechend zu reagieren oder die Landesbehörden zu tun.
Das ist ja auch erfolgt.
Und das hat dann auch erfolgt. Also wir sehen uns da halt nicht in irgendeiner Rolle, irgendwelche Ermittlungen da zu beeinträchtigen, sondern wir wollen halt einfach nur dafür sorgen.
Also ich meine, wir wollen sie schon beeinträchtigen, aber auf eine andere Weise. Also für mich ist es schon auch ein politisches Ziel zu sagen, das soll in Zukunft nicht mehr verwendet werden. Wenn sie Internet-Telefonie abhören wollen in Zukunft, dann müssen sie sich an die Anbieter wenden, die haben ohnehin Abhörschutzstellen. Also dafür einen Rechner zu infiltrieren, lehne ich grundsätzlich ab. Und das würde ich auch so kommunizieren. Insofern würde ich ihre Ermittlungen schon stören, in gewisser Weise nämlich, dass diese Praxis nicht mehr fortgeführt wird. Aber jetzt nicht für konkrete Verfahren.
Ne, gut, das wäre auch elegant.
Ja, dazu haben wir glaube ich auch zu wenig Einblick, was da gerade läuft in Bayern. Und da möchte ich, würde ich auch nicht. Haben wir auch glaube ich, ja, das hat glaube ich niemand bei uns irgendwie gestritten drüber.
Lustigerweise gab es ja so einen taktischen Effekt, der sich eigentlich ganz gut ausgezahlt hat. Dadurch, dass wir nämlich nicht gesagt haben, wo wir das haben, haben plötzlich alle möglichen Leute mit schlechtem Gewissen sehr zurückhaltend reagiert. Also unsere, wir haben ja so ein bisschen mit zwei Szenarien gerechnet. Entweder hier steht so ein Swat-Team und räumt uns die Bude aus.
Das ging ja aber nicht mehr.
Na ja, klar, aber das können die ja nicht wissen. Also die hätten schon irgendwie, ich meine, es gibt Präzedenzfälle dafür, dass sie irgendwie nervös reagieren.
Wir haben die Platten, die Platten sind nicht nirgendwo mehr, wo sie beschlagnahmt werden können. Wir haben die halt irgendwie in einem neutralen, sicheren Ort verbracht.
Die haben alle nochmal aufgeräumt.
Die haben alle nochmal aufgeräumt. Also, liebe LKAs, falls ihr jetzt gerade noch drüber nachdenkt, das würde nicht zum Ziele führen.
Das zweite szenario war, dass die alle sagen, nö, machen wir nicht. Ja, dass irgendwie einer übrig bleibt, irgendwie das LKA Helgoland, so sag ich jetzt mal überspitzt, und alle anderen sagen, würden wir nie machen.
Genau.
Und das war so ein bisschen die Idee. Und dann meldet sich halt überhaupt keiner. Also dann war irgendwie totale Funkstille.
Na ja, wir haben natürlich immer wieder hintenrum mal so gehört, was wir dort wohl mitgekriegt haben. Also es gab schon so wilden Telefonverkehr, da haben wir ja einige mitgekriegt, aber es kam halt keine offizielle Stellungnahme und dann kam diese Nachricht.
Und auch keine Drohung.
Ja, okay, aber dann kam halt diese Stellungnahme des Innenministeriums, dass es ja nicht der Bundestrojaner sein könnte, weil es eben nicht das BKA ist. Und interessant darin sind halt zwei Sachen. Zum einen, das ist halt ein unnötig spezifisches Dementi.
Warte mal, das ging noch weiter. Sie haben drei Behörden genannt, nicht nur das BKA.
Nicht streiten, meine Herren.
So, also keine Behörden unter Kontrolle des Bundes war ja ihre Sache. Und gefolgt von einem Hinweis darauf, dass die Länder selbst zuständig sind. Das heißt, zu diesem Zeitpunkt war denen schon vollkommen klar, dass es sich halt irgendwie im Landesbehörden handeln muss. Und sie wollten halt nur nicht sich da so weit aus dem Fenster lehnen. Aber interessant daran war, dass sie mit dieser umdefinition, dass sie gesagt haben, der Bundestrojaner ist der BKA-Trojaner. Und sie vorher auch gesagt haben, ja, sowas verwenden wir, aber es ist nicht diese Software. Haben sie versucht, die Debatte hinzubekommen auf einen, ist es denn der Bundestrojaner, ist es nicht der Bundestrojaner? Also ist es, also das kann ja gar nicht der Bundestrojaner sein. Was ist es denn dann? Und wir hatten das ja so ein bisschen vorhergesehen, deswegen wir uns ja auf die Terminologie Staatstrojaner geeinigt hatten. Für unsere Zwecke, weil es halt eben um staatliche Stellen geht, diesen Trojaner einsetzen. Und naja, und dann hatten sie natürlich jetzt das Problem, dass nach und nach halt dann immer klarer wurde, aus welcher Ecke es kommt. Also dass halt zumindest einer dieser Trojaner aus Bayern kommt, also dass der halt in diesem bekannten Landshuterverfahren eingesetzt wurde und dann heute eben sich die Ereignisse überschlugen und halt der der entsprechende Rechtsanwalt von dem einen Mann, der in diesem Verfahren bestätigt hat, dass er einer derjenigen war, die uns eine Platte geschickt haben.
Hat er von sich aus gemacht, hat zu kleiner Pressemitteilung gemacht. Und bei Ulf Bohrmeier im Blog, was danach gleich mal nicht mehr erreichbar war.
Es tut mir ja auch leid. Ich mach das ja nicht.
Er hat wieder gefieft.
Na ja, gut.
Ich habe jetzt die Menti zufällig rauskopiert. Ich kann das mal kurz vorlesen. Bundesbehörden, so versichert man im Hausfahnen, Innenminister Hans-Peter Friedrich, CSU, hätten sie nicht eingesetzt. Das habe eine erste Prüfung bei Bundeskriminalamt, Polizei und Verfassungsschutz ergeben. Also Bundespolizei. Es könne also nicht von einem Bundestoyaner die Rede sein, in Sachen Aufklärung sein, nun vor allem die Bundesländer gefragt.
Du verstehst immer, die verstehen das Bund als der Bund.
Ja, genau. Die sind halt alle irgendwie dabei, das von sich weg zu zeigen. Es ist so wie so ein Umleitungs... Der war's. Und es gibt auch schon Dementis in die Gegenseite. Ja, wir haben zwar ein Trojaner, hat irgendwie Brandenburg gesagt, aber das war Amtshilfe vom Bund.
Vom Bund, ja.
Es ist so richtig ein Theater gerade. Wir sind hier nur am Facepalm.
Welche Bundesländer haben nur gesagt, wir erzählen mal die aktuelle Lage. Ich bin nämlich der Einzige, der hier nicht chatet.
Okay, also der aktuelle Stand ist...
Was haben wir denn?
Also als Erstes hat Bayern eingeräumt, dass es ihr Trojaner hat. Dann kam NRW und hat eingeräumt, dass sie einen Trojaner ansetzen. Dann kam Niedersachsen und hat gesagt, sie setzen Trojaner ein. Mein Lieblingspolitiker.
Hat NRW eingeräumt?
NRW hat eingeräumt.
NRW hat doch dementiert erst mal.
NRW hat irgendwas eingeräumt.
Na gut, aber jedenfalls die letzte Meldung jetzt war gerade, dass Baden-Württemberg den Trojanereinsatz stoppt. Und die haben auch zugegeben, dass sie irgendwie Digitask verwenden, also dieselbe Basissoftware, wie sie sich nennen. Und dann hat jetzt am Ende auch noch der Rechtsanwalt der Firma Digitask, also der Hersteller dieses Trojaners, zugegeben, dass höchstwahrscheinlich Digitask der Hersteller dieser Software sei.
Oh, warte, das stimmt. NRW war eine andere Sache.
NRW hat auch so ein superspezifisches Demant hier abgegeben.
Und es gab ja diese großartige Pressemitteilung von Sophos, einem von dieser Anti-Viren-Hersteller. Die haben extra eine FAQ gemacht zu dem Trojaner. Und da steht dann so drin, ja, zu welcher IP kommuniziert der denn? Und dann sagen sie, das ist die IP so und so, die ist in Düsseldorf. Und dann so die nächste Frage, wo sitzt denn das LKA von Nordrhein-Westfalen? In Düsseldorf.
Also ich glaube, wir müssen eigentlich noch mal einen zweiten Podcast machen, wenn noch mal ein halbes Jahr rum ist.
Das ist einfach nur Comedy, diese ganzen...
Weil jetzt kommen die kleinen Anfragen, ja. Was wird jetzt passieren in den Landesparlamenten? Das ist ja auch schon, auch im Bundestag. Dann kommt nächste Woche die bundestags-innenausschuss-fraktion. Morgen gibt es das Hintergrundgespräch. Das heißt, eigentlich müssen wir nach dem halben Jahr nochmal resümieren. Genau zum Kongress, ne?
Na, das machen wir beim Kongress. Ich denke, dann ist schon genug. Machen wir eine Party.
Also ich werde das nicht mit euch machen, weil ich würde eigentlich gerne mal ein bisschen was zu der russischen Seite sagen.
Du willst was Konstruktives machen?
Ja, will ich schon gern. Und ich würde das gerne wieder mit Ulf machen.
Die russische Seite.
Ja, genau. Auch so ein bisschen, wie man sich das überhaupt vorstellen kann in Zukunft. Aber mal sehen, es ist ja noch ein bisschen hin bis zum Kongress. Könntet ihr ja so ein bisschen mal, einfach mal ein bisschen, weiß nicht, den Fallout mal nachzeichnen. Weil es wird ja jetzt noch eine Weile weitergehen.
Ja, das wird es auf jeden Fall.
Und die interessante Frage ist jetzt, unser Popcorn-Vorrat ist fast zu Ende.
Wo halt die diskussion hingeht? Und da muss es halt ganz klar darum gehen, welche Ermittlungswerkzeuge können die Behörden verwenden? Wer prüft, was mit diesen Ermittlungswerkzeugen ist? Und da laufen wir in das grundsätzliche Problem, was wir vielleicht auch nochmal erklären sollten, dass es zwar relativ gut möglich ist, nachzuweisen, dass Software eine bestimmte funktion erfüllt, aber es sehr schwer ist, nachzuweisen, dass Software eine bestimmte funktion nicht hat. Und genau da, das ist halt ein ziemlich grundlegendes Problem, die Informatik. Und die Problematik, dass eben softwarefunktion nicht haben soll, also dass zum Beispiel Nachladen von Code nicht in dieser Software enthalten sein soll, wurde auch schon vom Verfassungsgericht ausführlich gewürdigt. Genau das, was wir damals gesagt haben, was passieren wird, ist eben auch passiert. Also wir können uns jetzt irgendwie die großen Toytusso-T-Shirts anziehen.
Die haben wir doch sowieso immer an. Naja, also das Problem ist sogar für die Nummer größer. Wenn man das jetzt nur auf den strafprozessualen Bereich bezieht, das heißt, ich würde Dinge installieren, um Beweise zu sichern, dann kann man das von vornherein schon aus logischen Gründen knicken.
Weil man damit Beweise nachinstallieren kann.
Ja, also da kann man sich biegen und verrenken, da geht nichts raus aus dieser argumentation.
Das ist sogar noch weiter eigentlich, denn es gibt ja Anforderungen an Forensik. Also wenn eine Platte irgendwo ausgebaut wird und soll forensisch untersucht werden, dann darf man die auch nicht einfach irgendwo einbauen und mounten, oder gar noch ein Tool drauf kopieren. Die Anforderungen sind völlig klar, sobald der erste Schreibzugriff ist, ist das nicht mehr beweisfähig. Und wenn ich jetzt einen Trojaner aufspiele, dann habe ich einen Schreibzugriff. Also schon, das ist völlig wurscht, was der Trojaner für funktionalität hat. Wenn ich einen Trojaner aufspiele, habe ich Sachen verändert.
Er würde die jetzt vielleicht sagen, aber...
Rein fundamental juristisch ist damit Ende mit der Beweisbarkeit.
Ja, aber was heißt das jetzt? Präventiv, findest du das schon okay?
Ne, Trojaner gibt es nicht. Ist fertig.
Was wäre ein radikaler?
Natürlich.
Na einer muss ja.
Einer muss ja.
Na gut, dann haben wir sozusagen mal den kurzen aktuellen Rundumschlag.
Aber ich glaube, das sollten wir am Heimjahr, das wäre eigentlich schön, wenn man nochmal... Also die ganzen Dementis dann nochmal...
Also, ich würde sagen, das nochmal ordentlich aufrollen, was in den nächsten Tagen passiert.
Ich glaube, wir werden das auch in einer Mauschance...
Die werden die Zahlen nennen müssen, die würde ich gerne wissen. Ich bin gespannt.
Also interessant noch so eine hintergrundinformation ist, wir haben in den letzten beiden Tagen brutal viel Pressearbeit gemacht. Ich glaube, so viel wie noch nie.
Das war wirklich brutal. Brutalst möglich.
Das Interessante daran ist, die starke persönliche Betroffenheit bei den Journalisten.
Die waren alle sehr empört.
Bei allen Journalisten, die die Empörung sehr groß war.
So eine Frechheit.
Dass die alle sehr stark verstanden haben, dass das das Problem ist. Bis hin zu heute früh irgendwie der Taxifahrer, der mich durch den Ström im Regen gefahren hat und mich hier am Club absetzte und dann so guckte so, ach hier, Karls Computer Club meinte ja, coole aktion. Das heißt also, wir erfahren da auch gerade einfach eine Maß an Zustimmung, was wir so relativ selten hatten.
Nee, und ja, dass die Presse so, dass sie eigentlich durch die Bank sehr kritisch spricht, in unterschiedliche Aspekte betont, aber dass sich da niemand irgendwie auf die Urseite stellen will, das ist schon bemerkenswert. Und also ich hab das auch erlebt heute, wie viele Journalisten auch richtig empört waren, auch die Dreistigkeit, mit der sich über diese Entscheidung in Karlsruhe wissend und sehenden Auges hinweggesetzt wurde, dass auch nach drei Jahren da eigentlich, das ist überhaupt kein Einsehen, also das wird überhaupt nicht als Waffe gegen den Menschen und seine Intimsphäre gesehen, sondern das ist halt einfach, wo immer haben geht.
Jetzt von der Urseite meinst du.
Also da war viel Empörung.
Ja, aber das war doch klar.
Ich mein, wir haben das angesagt. Die meisten Leute rechnen doch, seit diesem ganzen Terror-Scheiß, rechnen doch eigentlich alle damit abgehört zu werden. Das ist ja auch letztendlich, würde ich das auch teilweise uns auf die Schultern legen, wir haben einfach dafür gesorgt, dass das bekannt wird, was der Staat alles machen darf. Wir haben gegen die BKA-Gesetze gekämpft, gegen die, dass die Polizisten ausgezeichnet werden, ist auch wieder so ein Ding in die Richtung, dass man denen nicht einfach trauen darf. Also diese Idee, dass man dem Staat nicht einfach trauen darf, das hat echt in der Bevölkerung Widerhall gefunden.
Die meisten Leute gehen davon aus, ja, aber das ist nicht selbstverständlich.
Und das ist inzwischen wirklich so, dass die Leute einfach auch davon ausgehen, dass sie vom Staat, wenn sie da nicht aufpassen, verarscht werden. Und das hat niemand wirklich überrascht, dass wir jetzt diesen Trojaner hatten. Wir haben also auch viele Mails gekriegt, wo Leute gesagt haben, ja, naja, das war ja auch mal Zeit jetzt.
So, genau, Zeit jetzt. Wir haben es, glaube ich, so einigermaßen rund geschafft.
Ja, aber trotzdem, im halben Jahr ist es bestimmt mal lustig, auf den Fallout zu fahren.
Wir machen das nochmal mit dem Fallout.
Ihr müsst mich ja nicht mitnehmen, ihr könnt es doch alleine machen, ich hör's mir auch an.
Aber wir haben uns doch mal wieder gerne hier.
Oder zum Kurs, ich weiß nicht, naja. Wahrscheinlich sowieso alle draus.
Dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Wenn euch diesmal gefallen hat, da gibt's noch so einen Flatter-Button. Und wir freuen uns natürlich wie immer auf Feedback und auf Themenvorschläge. Und dann vielen Dank fürs Hiersein. Tschüss und einen schönen Abend noch. Bis zum nächsten Mal.